This is Jocko podcast number one 69 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
And tonight we have a return guest by the name of Jodi Mitak.
So before listening to this podcast,
if you have not listened to podcasts 24 25 and one 11 then go back and listen to
those podcasts first so that you can hear about Jody's life growing up,
joining the Canadian army,
his trials and tribulations in the Canadian army,
his successes and his failures,
how he eventually became a sniper served overseas eventually in Afghanistan
where he was wounded,
badly,
lost both of his legs but drove on,
became a successful politician in the city of Ottawa and was carrying on with
his life.
But things were not as pretty on the inside as they might have appeared on the
outside.
And when Jodie came back on for podcast one 11 I had a suspicion that things
might not being going that great.
There seemed to be something lurking just beneath the surface and
for whatever reason,
and there is no good reason that I can give.
I didn't say anything.
And I actually talked to a couple of my buddies who thought the same thing,
who said,
man,
Jody didn't quite sound right on that.
And it was the same thing that I thought it was the same thing that I could
sense in my gut.
And my gut was right.
There was more going on behind the scenes.
And Jodi is back today to explain where he's been,
what happened,
how he slipped off the path and how he has gotten back on it.
So,
Jodi,
welcome back.
Thank you brother.
And I guess I mean that in more ways than one.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
So talk to me Bro.
She,
um,
getting wounded sucked and uh,
and you know,
you,
when,
when was I here?
Last
January,
2018,
I think.
Uh,
Kelly and I rolled through Kelly.
I wasn't there,
but I don't know if anybody can see or here,
but Kelly is my fiance and my best friend.
She's present and she's present and she's always watching on youtube and a,
so as our dog,
Athena.
Um,
but anyway,
yeah,
man,
I,
um,
I spent 2007 to 2017 pretending I had prosthetic feet that did I present.
It didn't matter.
I guess if I'd had my feet blown off.
And,
um,
Kelly saw what happened,
like at some point,
uh,
after I was elected,
um,
it was,
what was the position you were elected to?
City city counselors.
So I think,
I don't know,
you call them aldermen,
don't hear me.
Um,
and because I had just come off the amazing race Canada,
um,
and I was second place on that,
so I was popular in Canada.
And so that helped me win the election,
but also raise my profile in Canada.
And so they made me the sports commissioner for the city and I was the veterans,
a liaison and things like that.
And,
um,
like personal relationship wasn't going that well.
And you know,
things like that.
So things in the background,
like you said,
of life,
you know,
everyone says,
oh,
you look like the perfect family,
but you know,
like,
it's,
uh,
what else are you gonna put it on Facebook,
right?
I mean,
that's what it's for.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
we were just going in different directions and that's fine.
So I actually,
uh,
we actually split up and moved out and fall of 16,
and I found the politics job,
um,
frankly as eager and,
as I was to serve,
because politics,
despite what most people think is service to your country,
most politicians,
uh,
could probably make twice as much money doing other things.
And just like,
like when my book came out and Flinching,
um,
I had that deal in place before I started campaigning.
And I was like,
well,
and also the amazing race,
right?
So I was like,
one of these things will work out.
It turned out,
I,
I got,
uh,
you know,
what do you call it and craps where you throw and you get the dice are good.
Seven,
I've got seven with every role.
So the show worked and then the book work and then,
uh,
and then the election,
I want it.
So I had all these things to juggle,
you know,
and,
uh,
and when I bought,
when I got elected and I was like happy about it,
cause I was like medically retiring that in 2014 I medically retired and,
uh,
I didn't want to,
of course,
like all soldiers,
right.
We want to carry on.
I wanted to train more sniper then more troops.
But anyway,
I'm in service to my country.
Awesome.
And,
uh,
you know,
um,
people tell you something like,
uh,
you know,
going out for the seals,
that's not what you see on TV and it's this and that.
And you go,
yeah,
okay.
And of course you know that,
but until you're there,
there's really no way no one can prepare you for it.
Right.
You have to actually live it.
Yeah.
Like sniper school,
you have to go like,
there's no way to prepare unless you do it.
So,
uh,
politics is the same.
And I'm a straight guy and you know,
we are honorable men,
uh,
for the most part.
And we do our best to stick to our word and deed and,
and politics.
I'm not saying that it's not that,
but there's a whole lot of pretending.
Uh,
and by pretending,
I mean you have to say one thing and mean another and you know,
it's not necessarily lying,
but it's not necessarily the truth.
And,
and,
uh,
the political brinkmanship that is with that job means always holding your cards
very tight.
And,
um,
you know,
and I,
I don't want to,
I'm a,
I'm a combat guy,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm action.
I'm about getting things done and,
and although that worked in a lot of ways for politics and a lot of other ways
that it wasn't meshing,
so I had no,
I had a couple of colleagues on council that I,
that I liked and I hung out with.
But for the most part,
I didn't have any friends.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And my soldier,
uh,
brothers and sisters,
they were around,
but now I am this guy who's a politician and a bestselling author and I was on
amazing race.
So whenever I hung out,
it was like,
Hey,
let's talk about what you're doing.
Me.
And I'm like,
can we just talk about the last UFC or hey,
what's going on at the unit?
Or what's the latest equipment acquire,
acquired.
That's cool.
Um,
people are inviting me places.
I'm the guest of honor here and this,
and I'm,
I'm like,
I'm missing just being Jody.
Mm.
Um,
you know,
and,
and it got to a point where I was a,
and then on top of it,
my legs were not cooperating.
Like they just didn't want to take the beating of everyday life anymore.
And,
uh,
and so I started drinking again and,
and it was drinking to mask the pain mostly,
but also what does that look
Gleick when you,
first of all,
how,
how long had you stopped drinking for,
or did you,
I never stopped drinking,
but I was,
because I got addicted to the opioids.
Pardon me?
Because I got addicted to my oxycotton.
I didn't want to take pain meds,
so at the end of a day,
long day,
so I'd show up at the office,
usually between six and eight.
Um,
you know,
if,
depending on what was going on and what committees I was sitting on or if
council,
what meetings and,
and then politics is all about being places to shake hands as well.
And that's,
I love that part,
meeting people,
talking to people.
It's awesome.
I have no,
you know,
uh,
me and the mayor go along and I,
you know,
I get along with the other two levels of government and it was fun and you go
places and you represent veterans.
And that's the important thing for me.
And you know,
the whole point to get into politics was to be a better representative for my
brothers and sisters that are now veterans.
Yeah.
Cause I gotta throw this out there where you talked about how when you're a
politician,
you're serving your country.
And unfortunately there's a lot of politicians that when they're politicians,
they're serving themselves.
And I'm sure you must've seen that.
And I know that's what makes people get that stereotypical negative attitude
towards politicians because oftentimes politicians are just looking out for
their best interests and whether that means they're doing things inside their
district because they just want to get something for themselves,
like more money.
But,
but oftentimes if they're just doing what they need to do to get reelected,
I was just still self serving.
Well that's the funny thing with politics is if yourself serving,
hmm.
It's,
it's,
it's a catch 22 what you write and you just,
you just pointed it out,
right?
Like if I get reelected,
I can still continue to do this for my community,
but I have to get reelected.
So I do this to get reelected and then I can do this for my community.
It's kind of like that.
Play the game.
Yeah.
It's that a,
your favorite word,
the dichotomy of,
of politics.
So,
um,
quite often though,
I found myself,
uh,
like there was one thing where my staff was and it was,
and it's,
you know,
the stupidest things,
uh,
can,
can get you at,
especially at city level,
the hardest level of politics.
And I in Canada anyway,
I don't know about here,
but is the city level,
the municipal level because you are,
you are plugged into 90% of most people's daily lives.
Flushing water,
flood our toilets,
flushing water,
running nine one one working the dog park w you know,
of being cleaned up the grass,
you know,
snow plowed.
If you're in Canada here I guess,
uh,
I don't know.
What do you guys have storm drains that may be get plugged now and then potholes
and bottles,
portals,
a huge issue in Ottawa actually.
Um,
uh,
so you know,
it's,
you're always on,
so you go around,
you meet people and so,
you know,
I love that part,
but my legs started to just go and so I didn't want to take the pills.
And,
and what causes that?
Is it just I'm rich and beat down on your legs?
Yeah,
well it's like a,
you know,
your,
your elbows are designed for,
you know,
certain amount of weight bearing.
Right.
And the skin there and can handle it.
But now try weight bearing on your for,
you know,
uh,
unless you really work at it.
You know,
uh,
and even then the skin there will never take weight like your elbows will.
And that's what happens with,
with prosthetics and with amputation and,
and so,
um,
I was also wearing my legs and a what's called a suction with a suction system.
And so what that is,
is the,
the liner around my,
that I put over my leg before I put them into the socket has like a gasket and
it pushes the air route.
Uh,
and it's a one way valve.
And so then it's like,
and so it's a vacuum,
right?
And so that vacuum was constantly pulling on the leg and for most people have no
issue,
but for whatever reason,
um,
and I looked around and I realized that most double below knee amputees use a
sleeve.
So now I use a sleeve,
but at the time,
cause every layer is that much more a dexterity lost in the movement of your
knee.
Your odd.
Right.
And I'm like,
I think I was telling an echo before the show.
Like,
I've,
I've done things with prosthetics that most of the guys that make them are like,
I've never seen anybody break it this way.
Like,
or I've never seen this type of damage or like you did what?
you're not supposed to do these things,
but as a double amputee.
And so I just wanted to most mobility possible,
but I was actually losing mobility because of the pain that I was putting myself
through.
So my bought my skin just couldn't handle that constant suction.
And so,
um,
so I was drinking,
you know,
I tough it out,
grit my teeth and at the end of the day we'd go to the pub next to city hall,
have a few drinks,
talk some politics and usually I'm the last one there.
And,
and then like,
you know,
did it escalate to that?
Where,
where he like,
oh yeah,
we're going to have a couple of drinks.
And then it's like,
oh yeah,
a couple of drinks and most people are gone.
That's all.
I'm still fine.
And then eventually you look around and you're like,
oh,
I'm the last person here.
Oh,
it's been three weeks since I've been the last person here.
It was like three months.
Yeah,
it was six months.
And then like,
and I was known now,
you know,
and then in city count,
like the insight politics of,
of City Hall was Jody,
you know,
if you want a party called Jody,
or if our,
where's Jody at?
That's where the fun is.
And you know,
and I'm not saying like,
it was like crazy,
uh,
things that you see on a house of cards or anything like that.
But if there was an event,
I was there,
you know,
and you know,
and again,
like for a bit of it was avoiding going home and dealing with that situation
properly.
And then
the more pain I was in and then,
you know,
and then the more pain I'm in the morning I'm drinking,
and then the more I'm drinking and then,
um,
you're just putting yourself through more damage,
right?
Like you're out later,
but because you're not feeling it,
you're out later,
then you're causing more damage.
Right.
So I move out fall of 16 and then in spring of 17,
my legs are just,
they're done.
They're just like,
I,
I uh,
I came back,
I did this thing in Canada called Canada reads and it's a national thing where
like you,
you read a book and then you try to get it to win the contest and it's a week in
Toronto.
And um,
and I did that and I gritted my way through it.
And then I got home and I was at my old house with,
with my ex and my kids and,
and uh,
and I took my legs off after,
cause I just,
I went there straight from the flight because I wanted to see the girls and I
took my legs off and like she would like my ex,
she was there the night I was wounded and she said that she'd never heard me in
the 10 years.
She's known me make those types of paint sounds from pain and cause I took my
legs off and it was,
it was just like torture.
Like,
because while you have the pressure on and,
and,
and you're using them like a kind of,
you know,
when you sprain an ankle,
maybe you know when you go around on it,
but at the end of the day when you get off,
take the weight off,
that's when it really hurts.
Um,
that's basically it would happen.
And she was like,
wow,
I've never heard you make those noises.
You must be in real pain.
So after that I just couldn't wear my legs anymore.
And that's like,
I mean I saw you almost a year later.
I was still in my wheelchair.
Yeah.
How much of that is,
I know you were going hard working hard.
cause you're spending an extra three,
four hours a day standing around at the bar drinking.
How much of that is because the damage that alcohol is doing to your system you
oh yeah.
How much of it is self imposed?
A good 50% I'd say.
Yeah.
I mean just getting out of bed and putting the legs on hurt and then,
you know,
it's like,
again,
when you,
I always go to the ankle because I used to spray in them a lot when I had them
and,
um,
and that sucks as an infantry guy,
but I learned how to tape them and I did some exercises but,
but you know,
like once getting into your boot or once you're in there though,
when you lace it up and you're usually good to go with it,
right?
So that's what I was doing every single morning for like a year.
And,
and then like,
and then,
you know,
I'm just going to say it now,
I started abusing cocaine and then to go,
because you know,
when you have a few drinks a,
you start to wobble and,
and unfortunately I picked up the habit after my first rotation,
Afghanistan.
It was like,
kind of like,
uh,
seeking that thrill again.
I don't know.
I'm sure you've had a lot of troops to tell you this type of thing,
but,
um,
and,
and it goes out of your system.
And a couple of days,
and whereas we'd is there for months at a time,
you know,
and I don't know.
I've,
no,
I hadn't,
I hadn't touched anything since like high school.
When my buddies,
hot mom sold Hash and me and my other buddy would want to hang out and buy,
I'd buy it.
I never,
I only smoked it like three times,
but anyway,
um,
then you're out even longer and you're still wearing your legs even longer.
And you know,
and any
was the,
what was the,
how did you do,
you kind of just said,
oh yeah,
I was drinking and then I was doing some cocaine.
And for me,
that's a big step.
Like,
I mean,
well,
we need to,
because here's the thing,
I want people to understand what opened that door up.
What made you say to yourself,
you know what,
um,
I'm a politician or I'm a wounded vet.
I can do kind of whatever I want.
Well,
that was part of it.
Yeah.
Um,
I,
because I had so much success and I was so much,
um,
you know,
it was my name on the,
on the door.
Uh,
you know,
and,
and at first,
like I went in with full intentions of being,
doing the honorable thing and this and,
and being,
being a standup guy.
And,
and I,
I think I was for a lot of part,
but where I started going down is when it was the booze and the,
and the coke started to fill in the gaps where I should have been at home or in
the gym or,
or things like I was seeking immediate reward,
you know,
like I would like say a powered through a week of pain and,
and like getting up early and going,
cause I was true right up until I moved out of the house.
Like I was training for a bodybuilding show.
I was looking good as feeling good.
I was going here,
I was going there,
I kind of started feeling arrogant,
you know,
like I,
I'm Jody medic and I work my ass off and I'm going to party my ass off this
weekend because I can't.
And then it went from the weekend too.
Okay.
It's Thursday.
Uh,
you know,
and we got no meetings tomorrow at City Hall.
So I'm going to sleep in tomorrow because tonight I'm going and there's always
events.
There's always events where you can go and eat and drink and meet people and
look cool.
And,
and I was the guy who had did amazing race,
wrote a book or got wounded in Afghanistan,
powered is way back,
Dah,
got elected.
You know,
like I was always on display.
It felt,
you know,
so when I was allowed to be myself,
I kinda just let loose,
you know,
I'd like light the fuse on the,
on the rocket.
And
when advising you,
was anyone pulling you aside going,
hey bro,
you know,
no,
because I was the man
in my world.
I was,
I was in charge.
I like my assistant.
Um,
he tried his best,
but you know,
it's not something like,
um,
like even even killed,
right?
She was around for a little bit.
Like,
it's not something you just walk up and go,
Hey Jocko,
you don't fucking sorry.
are you doing coke?
You don't,
unless you have that relationship with someone,
you can't just open that door.
Right.
Um,
like it's your door.
You,
are you,
are you jack and needles up your arm?
Like are you doing heroin?
Like you know what I mean?
Like you can't just so,
and like I said,
I was the man in my life.
My whole world was like,
I was so in charge.
Yeah.
I kind of drank my own koolaid for awhile.
I talk about it.
You go obviously all the time.
And one of the things I say when I talk about ego is,
is when you start believing your own hype right now bro,
it's the worst.
And if you put yourself in a position where no one even has the balls to come up
to you and say,
Hey,
I think you could do this a little bit differently.
And even if they do or they try to hint at it,
you kind of steam roll them cause you're the man and this is what that situation
is where you aren't looking at yourself thinking,
okay,
what am I really doing right now?
How is this working out well to,
in my view for a long time?
And it all worked out fine.
Yeah.
Which all that does is solidify your beliefs.
Like you're on the show.
You come in second,
but you came in second with no legs.
That is pretty much like place right.
Sprinted past a sprinter.
Like that girl,
Selena,
she was a sprinter in high school and I sprinted pastor,
you know,
um,
and I'm,
I'm getting older and you know,
my,
you know,
I'm just,
I was what?
Yeah,
it just,
but when it started being like,
it was a,
it was a Saturday night and then it was a weekend and then it was like a four
day weekend.
And then next thing I knew I was out because,
you know,
I didn't need to go home.
Uh,
and I saw the kids on the weekends and stuff,
so I just,
I was able to manipulate my,
and I'm the boss of my own schedule.
You're manipulating everything,
including yourself because you're big nationalizing.
It's so funny because it's not like you don't see this play out over and over
and over again with,
uh,
with famous people,
famous people that all of a sudden they get,
they get a role in a movie or they,
they do something,
they,
they get recruited to a professional sports team and next thing you know,
no one can tell them anything and they're going to go and they're going to go
hard.
And the other thing that happens is you get surrounded with yes men,
people that are just telling you,
oh yeah,
yeah,
you do whatever you want.
And in my opinion,
a lot of times those,
yes men there,
they're actually digging dirt they're actually possibly do while they're either
trying to hook on to you and get what they can out of you and ride your
coattails.
Or there's someone that just looking for,
to make you fall down because they're jealous a hundred percent I was surrounded
by both and I'm not,
and it,
hey,
if you were around me and you're listening to this,
I'm not saying that was you,
but there are some people that might be listening that know exactly what they
were in my life at the time.
And looking back on it,
it's like,
you know,
it's like doing a map recky after the,
after the mission or something and then you go,
oh,
how did I not see that right there?
That object or that obstacle right there.
How did I miss that when it's so obvious?
So you know I spent,
so I think it's important to like just pause for a second though,
because people go into these situations all the time and what you have to do is
you have to be,
you have to do is map study.
Like you're saying,
you have to do a reconnaissance.
You have to look around and say,
hey,
maybe I don't know exactly where I am.
Maybe I need to look for some of these obstacles.
Maybe I need to look for some of these obvious pitfalls that I'm going to look
back in five years and I'm going to say,
oh,
that person was a Leech or oh,
I was being an idiot.
Or Oh everyone was fueling the fire so they could get more out of me.
And when,
when that's the way it is.
If you're aware of that,
that you're going to get yourself from that situation.
The problem is,
the problem is you get in that situation,
you're supposed to be self aware but you can't because you're in that situation,
right?
It's a,
it's a catch 22
and I've got to tell you,
man,
um,
when you're doing the amount of drinking and then the amount of drugs I was
doing,
it's impossible.
Do your,
your,
your ability to sync objective Lee and,
and self like they self awareness dissolves and guys like you and me and at
worst,
you know,
we're warriors were elite,
this and that.
We're supposed to have it all together,
but it's actually,
it's super common in our,
in our,
uh,
in our community.
And it's because we're so used to being on point.
I think for me what happened was I was so used to being on point that it just
never occurred to me.
I was,
and it to occur.
My kids,
even my mom,
my dad,
my brother and my sister,
my assistance,
um,
my,
a couple of good friends,
um,
to kind of just start to turn the ship.
And when I was here last time,
the ship had just barely started to turn.
I had just before we came,
drove down here,
um,
I just quit drinking and,
uh,
at new years,
which was actually pretty easy.
And you know,
I just,
I hadn't used since we tired of the road trip and we saw you like,
I think in the last half of it.
So,
um,
and I felt like,
oh,
I don't,
obviously I'm not addicted.
I,
I can go three weeks or whatever it was.
And um,
and so 2017 was the down and then 2018 was a bit of a leveling out.
And then I had a hard crash right before new year's this year or,
yeah,
I guess whatever.
A couple of months ago.
And that's when her Kelly and everyone said,
if you don't go to rehab,
you're going to lose it all.
I have to back up because I know,
sorry man,
you jumped like you're like oh that are them to crash.
And
we're good.
Cause I,
cause what for me,
what I want to see is I want to be able to recognize the warning signs better.
Right.
Yeah.
I know.
And I'm,
I'm trying,
I'm,
I'm glossing because you asked me did you get in trouble
with your governmental job,
with your political positions?
Did people eventually say,
cause I remember at one point you missed a meeting,
you missed some meetings and,
and all of a sudden it turned into,
hey,
what's this guy's problem?
Yes.
So in politics,
you know,
as much as you're your own boss and you know,
for,
for municipal level,
uh,
in Canada and Ontario because we don't have a party system at that level,
apparently you had your own party.
So stir frys partying.
I,
you know,
I was the party,
um,
uh,
the,
the time when you were earning is when it's budget time.
And that's where you're fighting for your,
you,
you're a community.
Get the dollars that it deserves or the programs,
pardon me,
sorry.
The programs that you believe in,
you're,
you're there to say,
I think that this needs more money or this shift.
That's when you really make your,
make your money or make,
earn your pay as a politician so to,
so to speak.
And,
and I just stopped showing up.
You can mess up the whole year,
but if you're not there for budget,
that's when people started going,
hey man,
what's going on?
And a really good friend of mine who is one of the biggest things,
the biggest meetings of the year,
and I missed important things that you have to do,
the most important things you have to do to represent the community that elected
you and you're just not showing up.
I just,
uh,
yeah,
just tell him I won't be there today.
And Mike Assistance is like,
dude,
I can't keep covering for you.
You know,
and a good,
a good friend of mine who's also a big political reporter in Canada called me
one day and he said,
you need to meet me for lunch or you just,
you like,
you got to say something or else you're going down.
And I was like,
what?
And so I met him for lunch and I didn't really didn't want to.
And,
and he's like,
this is what's gonna be said if you don't say anything.
And he's like,
I'm telling you this as a friend,
I've known you since way before you.
You were Jody Mitic,
I've known you for and I respect you and your,
you've always been straight and you've stopped.
You're not being straight anymore and you're not being honest and you're not
answering questions.
And he's like,
this is the world you're in now,
dude.
Like this is how you have to handle it.
And so coming down and doing your show last time was kind of part of that.
Come to Jesus when you want you to do w did you do like a story with that
reporter and say I've been,
you did sort of a,
I'm guilty but I only just told half the story.
Kind of like,
like I was telling you half extreme ownership.
I took half of the ownership,
I admitted to drinking,
but I couldn't,
I still didn't have it in me to admit to the drugs.
And,
um,
and then what was the reaction of the public support?
Mostly a lot of them.
I mean the politics,
the best part of what politics is,
no matter how awesome you think you are,
there's always someone,
even if you are as awesome as you think you are,
someone out there,
he's going to say,
no,
you're not.
And,
and so I had 90% of the public say,
you know,
we understand and you've been through a lot and this and that and,
and we support you.
We're here for you and fight on and you're a fighter.
And it was love.
And I,
and I took it in and,
and it fueled me honestly for a long time through 2018.
I really,
it was trying and,
and uh,
you know,
when I went back and did a few updates,
you stopped drinking?
Yeah,
I could.
Yeah.
I quit drinking new.
We quit drinking.
Both of us quit during New Year's Eve.
So the interview is December,
I want to say 18th ish.
2017.
So New Year's Eve,
we stopped drinking.
Um,
and then I spent the rest of the year trying to the rest of 2018.
I have,
especially after the,
I stopped wearing your shirts.
Oh,
good.
Right.
The good with the face.
Those are the shirts I have of yours.
I couldn't like my,
in my mind,
I didn't deserve it.
I couldn't even like your books are up on the shelf.
I couldn't even look at it.
My book is up on a shelf.
I couldn't look at it.
I,
um,
2018 I like,
yeah,
I stopped drinking and I admitted to my problem,
but then I had to deal with the emotional and psychological effects of realizing
I'm a complete loser.
In my mind.
Right.
Like if,
cause as a kid when you grew up,
what was somebody who did drugs a loser?
What was someone that,
so when you drove still doing cocaine at this time?
Oh yeah.
Well I had a break.
I did,
I managed to stop for a bit,
but you know,
my relationship with my,
with my former partner wasn't,
was anything but,
but awesome and you know,
and it's not saying bad or good about me or her,
but it's just like,
that's what happens in a relationship,
breaks up.
I'm under massive scrutiny by the public and the media.
Now in Ottawa,
I'm under,
I'm under a lot of,
just a lot of different stressors are coming in,
you know?
Um,
I just,
I just couldn't get anything together,
Dude.
I managed to stop drinking and that was about my only success.
So does the coke make you feel like a momentary,
like,
okay,
I've got this,
or does it just cover it up?
It's funny how it makes you think of other things.
Uh,
at first you just,
everything is awesome,
but eventually it stops working and it stops,
starts being like,
it's an opposite.
And it's,
it's just like they say it is.
Eventually it starts to try to rewire your brain.
I remember coming off oxy cotton and it was harder than getting wounded and
coming off coke isn't harder than getting wounded,
but it's easier to get back on.
Does that make sense?
I probably quit three times a week for a while.
They're like,
I'd go two or three days and I'd be like,
Oh,
I'm doing good today.
I didn't go into it.
And then the slightest like push like that,
I don't know if they can see that on the camera.
I'm pushing a water bottle.
I'll see it.
Oh,
there it is.
I'm pushing it.
The slightest push one half a degree off my axis on the compass.
And that was it.
That was it.
April and about.
Oh,
I didn't get,
I didn't drink.
Uh,
but it was like,
well,
I need it.
The slightest stressor.
And I would,
and I'd go off and I just,
I stopped having the ability to deal with life's my life's problems,
you know?
And on top of that,
for a lot of that year,
uh,
oh no.
Well 20 after I got back from the road trip where I saw you guys last,
I did put my legs back on.
Um,
but just like,
not like just every time I felt like I was like,
I'd go up a couple rungs in the ladder,
I'd fall back a couple and I was making progress,
but not the kind of progress someone like me is used to.
Like,
I'm used to like being in control.
And if I didn't want to do something,
I don't do it.
And if I want to do something,
I do it.
And this is one of those ones.
And I remember when I admitted to my psychologist,
truth has,
and I assumed it to sue thousand nine ish.
Uh,
cause I,
like I said,
I picked up,
I tried cocaine back in 2003,
four,
um,
after my first road would Afghanistan and you know,
and it was like,
okay,
cool,
whatever.
Uh,
it didn't really do it,
think about it for a long time after,
but she said that that one,
that one could get you just be careful.
Uh Oh,
she actually said watch out.
This is in 2009 after I'm wounded.
She said,
well what do you do to strap to relieve stress?
I'm like,
well you know,
on the weekends I,
my girlfriend and I will drink and do little and,
and she's like,
what?
Coke?
Ooh.
She's like,
you have a real casual way of saying sorry man,
it's my life.
But it's seat.
Cause I admitted to her,
cause I try,
no matter what,
you need someone you can talk to.
I have,
I've always believed that.
You know what too,
sometimes people develop personalities that they,
they managed to figure out how to make things happen.
Right.
So for instance,
some people they just have a way of talking to you.
You ever known someone that can like say something really horrible but they,
but then they say something else,
they kind of like can recover from it.
You don't feel all that bad or you get,
so it sounds like maybe you developed a technique of being like just talking
about this in such a way that people go,
oh,
you know,
he's,
if he's talking about this as such a controlled way and it's not that big of a
deal,
you know,
that's probably not that big of a deal cause that's what you're talking about it
to me,
that's how I talked about it to myself because I even had a military doctor and
I don't even know if this is a real thing.
Tell me I have an Auntie addictive personality,
right?
You,
you're getting the most,
and this is what's called re you're getting the biggest reinforcements for your
bad behavior.
Oh,
everything you do,
you,
you win and succeed even though you're doing stuff wrong.
Imagine if I had done everything sober,
you know,
like,
um,
but,
but yeah,
anyway she said that and that and that echoed and then you know what I,
I,
I didn't even realize the,
I don't even know what word do you use?
Like the fact that I almost lost my career in the 90s because I was with a
friend who bought cocaine and you can read that in the book.
And I think we talked about it,
but,
and I didn't,
I'd never done it at that point.
And I didn't want to do it,
but I didn't want my friend to go alone into some sleazy Bart barn anyway.
And here I am,
all rationalization by the way.
And you're 100% rational.
That was in 97.
Here I am in 2017 losing everything to cocaine,
losing everything.
And I thought oxycotton was my problem,
right?
Or the booze.
And it turns out like it just,
I couldn't slay this dragon,
you know.
Um,
so,
you know,
2018 was a lot of up and down,
up and down,
up and down.
And,
and yeah,
I gloss over it because it's,
there's too much to talk about on a podcast,
but you and I would message back every now and then.
And even the last show you said,
yeah,
well yeah I went through my your texts and,
and uh,
I saw you said the enemy oh flank to me and this and that.
29,
18 was me figuring out how to regroup and reorganize and,
and I'm still,
and I realized too dude,
like uh,
anyone who's been wounded in action or hurt in life recovery is it takes a team.
It's taken me 12 years and I'm not even recovered from getting blown up yet.
You know,
right before the show we were talking about,
and I think we probably talked about the first time I was here,
cause I recognize this a long time ago.
I always prepared to die or get that awesome wound I can brag about at the
barbecue when I'm old,
we send a lot of bandages in body bags,
Afghanistan as a,
as a force.
And I think you,
you guys did too.
At first we didn't even think about all the career ending injuries that are
possible.
You know,
cause we aren't draftees,
they went aren't the greatest generation work professional soldiers.
I saw myself retiring at a,
I don't know what the age is here,
but probably 55 grizzled old sergeant or warn officer,
you know,
go and then teach,
teach shooting at the,
the Canadian army sniper school,
you know,
as a,
as a contractor or something or I dunno,
I just never saw myself not being a soldier.
And,
and you know what I realized this the other day,
the politics was a bandaid.
The TV shows,
the books,
the podcasts,
these are all a part of me finding a way,
but I'm back.
You know,
I'm,
I'm instructing,
shooting again,
you know,
with some of my friends.
I'm back to,
uh,
advocating for veterans again,
you know,
which I can have time for him.
I'm trying to work.
I quit.
I could have run again for politics and one easily,
even with all my troubles.
Um,
I see.
I didn't want to,
I want to be like,
Jocko,
I want to work for myself.
No,
dude,
listen.
Well,
I don't work for myself.
When you were,
I think even the first or definitely the second time you came down and you're
telling me about all this,
all this stuff that you have to put up with every day,
all these people that you're dealing with,
and I just said,
bro,
why don't you just not do that job again?
Because the job satisfaction that you're getting out of it is none.
I mean,
maybe you're getting a little bit,
but basically you're not getting any real job satisfaction.
You're having to say things that you don't really feel like saying you're having
to talk to people that you really don't feel like talking to.
And meanwhile you're dealing with the fact that you lost your legs in
Afghanistan every freaking day as a is a is as presents challenges anyways,
and then you're presenting yourself with challenges that you don't enjoy it
because it's one thing to say,
oh,
I'm going to go do Jujitsu today and it's a challenge,
but it's a challenge I enjoy,
or,
oh,
I'm going to go for a run today,
but it's a challenge.
I enjoy it.
It's another thing to say,
I'm going to go do this challenge that I do not like and I don't get anything
out of that.
To me was,
was worrying to me it was the first time we met and we were at echoes brothers
company where podcast was.
And you,
your advice rang.
You know,
Kelly and I had a long talk before I announced I wouldn't run again.
And she said the same thing.
She says,
remember what Jockos said the squeeze isn't worth the juice or like that's the
way she put it.
But that's,
she was,
when I got home,
I told her what we talked about and Kelly and I were just friends back then and
a and stuff.
But um,
you know,
it,
that was a big,
my sister,
my baby sister actually she see said,
uh,
you know,
I knew you wouldn't last in politics,
not,
and she,
and it wasn't an insult.
You said you're just,
you're not,
you're not the right person.
Like your personality isn't,
isn't for the political side of things.
And,
and I want to work for myself and I love,
my podcast is backup.
We've done a couple of episodes,
you know,
we're still figuring it out.
Kelly and I want to do online coaching now for people.
Like we've got some hard,
hard miles between us,
so we want to try and help people avoid some of the things we've gone through.
And,
um,
and we're started and I'm just starting to like wander.
I'm becoming like,
uh,
the guy in,
we're,
we're big.
We,
I should say,
because we're a team.
Um,
we're like the guy in Kung Fu,
we just wander.
We're just gonna wander onto the earth,
wander the earth,
and,
and make our own schedule.
And,
uh,
but we,
you know what,
we do more work in a day now.
Like it,
it doesn't seem like work,
but we get more accomplished in a day or two now than we used to in two weeks
because it's for ourselves and it's just,
and it's fun now,
but I mean when we're just starting.
But I mean,
you know,
back to the story,
I just,
um,
I lost myself and I finally have come,
I think close to full circle back to who I was except,
you know,
I'm 42 and I accept that I lost my legs and I accept that my career ended and I
accept that I'm a complete mess up if I let myself be and I accept that I'm a
human being because of it.
Cause I don't know anyone who doesn't have any flaws.
But you're,
you're extreme ownership.
And the way I,
I've always,
even before I had a term,
extreme ownership,
ask anyone who knows me,
I might not tell you that all of the things about me or about my life,
but I'm not going to bullshit you.
And I'm not gonna lie about things that don't matter.
And I know everything matters.
If something can matter.
If you're not lying about something because it doesn't matter,
but there's some things that are none of your business.
But I even,
you know,
anyone who knows me knows that I don't bullshit for the most part.
You know,
cause you know,
sometimes I'll mess with it with you just for fun,
but,
and that's just the way I want to live my life.
And,
and,
and I was bullshitting myself.
Ew,
you,
her,
my kids,
the public,
all the people that supported me supported me for half truth.
This is why I told you your listeners deserve to have Jody Mitic come back and
say,
hey guys,
cause a lot of your listeners bro,
like,
dude,
I,
you know,
I don't want to tear up or anything because I'm a man or you know,
whatever.
But I get a message minimum one a week since the last show,
minimum,
often it's for five,
10.
Uh,
hey man,
I heard you on Jocko.
Thanks for being so truthful about your problems.
And it helped me quit drinking here.
It helped me get back into Jim and it and I'm like,
fuck,
I had to come back and just say,
hey guys,
like I,
you're,
you're back in the gym.
I ain't even been to the gym since October,
2016,
you know,
I know you can't believe it,
but,
uh,
good genetics,
good genetics.
But I mean,
I'm just saying like,
I felt like a fraud dude and I hated it.
And like she would watch me,
like just,
I would get a message and I'd be like,
you know,
I'd like throw the phone and she'd be like,
you should get another message from someone who heard you on Jocko.
And I'm like,
Yup.
And I,
my podcast is nowhere to be found in the book.
I could've made twice as much money on that book if I had been put together
enough up here to tour with it more to go over them.
And I still could have done my job,
but I,
I was compromising myself so much on,
on the,
on the front end that on the backend I couldn't keep it up,
you know.
So I had to,
it was like do,
do politics well or do the book well,
can't do both.
Well I stopped being able to multitask and everything and I just wanted to come
on the show and say sorry to you guys and all the listeners and just say,
and I know a lot of them will say,
you don't always say I owe you add for me please.
You know I owe you guys,
you guys supported me,
but you deserve the truth.
And the truth is I was doing a lot more than drinking and I did 30 days in Rehab
at the end of the law.
When did I go in?
Right after Christmas.
And I am back on a path of righteousness,
if you want to call it that.
I am trying to atone.
Uh,
I'm trying to rebuild some bridges.
I burned and I've had people not returned my call and I don't blame them.
I was a bit,
I was,
I was that guy you see in the movies for good,
solid three,
three months there.
At the end of the year,
I went full,
I don't want to say that word,
but I went,
I just,
I went full,
full dummy.
Uh,
and I,
and I realize that and you know,
so that's why I'm here.
Was there a point,
what led you to say
that you are going to go to Rehab?
I mean for the Cliche is,
you know,
what was rock bottom?
At what point did you look at yourself and say,
damn,
I gotta get my shit together now.
My girls needed me.
Kelly needed me,
my mom needed me,
my dad,
my,
if,
if everyone in your life is telling you there's a problem,
there's a problem.
And they managed to get through the static,
uh,
that was in my head.
And Kelly has had some serious health issues that weren't being helped by my
behavior to say the least.
Um,
she suffered,
uh,
do you mind if I told them?
So she had a hysterectomy right in 25,
2017,
which is all part of the story.
And she almost died on the operating or she then got sepsis and then almost died
at the time.
Our relationship wasn't an open thing.
Um,
and I couldn't be there for her.
And then my legs stopped working and we couldn't be there for each other,
even in private.
And uh,
and then so that was 2017.
So she's trying to,
um,
look after me and,
and herself and her and her,
her own relationship changing.
But anyway,
um,
so she had,
she had a cardiac moment from the stress of watching me destroying myself.
So Kelly had a cardiac moment,
my daughters were crying,
you know,
where's Daddy,
where you're always,
and then you're always late to get us or,
and then when we're with you,
you sleep.
And uh,
and my mom,
for my mom and my dad to agree on something,
which is Jody needs help was another light bulb.
And I was still in here somewhere like Jodie was still there and trying his best
and being so self reflective.
And if you ever have to go in through anything like this,
again,
this is something you can't,
no one can describe and everybody's is different and you're looking for the rock
bottom.
I had a couple and every one of them was in my,
and from my point of view,
my relationship with the people I love was on thin ice.
You know,
if my best friend,
my soulmate and my future wife,
the person I want to marry is saying,
I,
my health cannot sustain this so I will have to leave you because for,
for my own health,
nevermind you,
you're my health.
That's when I was like,
okay,
well obviously obviously I got it.
This isn't working.
What does it look like day to day when you're doing so much cocaine that it's
causing all these issues?
Cause I actually don't know and I probably never will know.
Hopefully.
And if you do,
I'll fly down here and we'll figure it out.
But that's the thing is,
uh,
you honestly believe everyone's against you.
Um,
you honestly believe there is no right move.
You can make except calling that guy who has the stuff.
And then,
and even though I got to a point where I knew exactly where doing the coke would
lead and I didn't care,
I didn't care.
I'd waste another day,
uh,
or another,
it usually it was three days and we're,
we're completely wasted.
Cause what,
what does that look like?
When you waste three days?
You,
you buy a bunch of cocaine,
you do a bunch and then you know,
you can only do so much right before he just feel like crap.
You just,
you physically just can't do more than you can or you could and you know,
and because of who I am and the way my mind works,
I'm always aware of,
okay,
there's oding as possible.
Uh,
there's just your body can physically give out if you like.
Your body needs sleep.
Right.
Were three trained for that.
Like we were trained like,
and so I didn't have all this information.
And also,
you know,
I knew a guy who is Canadian Special Operations Regiment.
I didn't really know him that well,
but in his mind,
he and he would break.
You would say,
I know what I'm going to,
if I'm going to die in a room for the cocaine and hookers.
And he did.
He did it to him,
but he wanted to,
I didn't want to die.
I have no interest in dying.
Um,
so,
you know,
I have all these factors and then it's weird.
But at the near the end I was,
oh,
sorry.
And here's another rock bottom moment.
I started buying booze again because booze and coke,
like one brings you up and then the other one brings you down.
And they Kinda,
that's why they go together so well.
And if that's what you're looking for it,
but don't kids.
Okay.
Um,
so when you do a bunch of coke,
what are you,
when you say you waste three days,
what are you doing?
Nothing.
It's not like hyper productive.
Hey,
I'm going to go.
Right.
And you are not,
when you're in the state of mind.
I was at first.
Yeah,
a little bit.
What?
Take you through the weekend and you'd get,
you'd get your email inbox will be empty.
Uh,
it might not make,
some of your replies might not make a lot of sense,
but you get through them.
Um,
you might read that book,
you've been wanting to do it and you might binge watch like friends or
something.
You know,
I've binge watched a lot of mindless TV on coke,
like friends.
How I met your mother.
Uh,
the show house,
uh,
scrubs,
things that didn't matter because I couldn't watch,
I love documentaries,
but I couldn't watch them because they made me too sad.
And then I couldn't watch ones that were about people like success stories
because then I'd feel like a failure.
So I watched all of this meaningless TV and that's what I would do.
She'd come by and I'd watching like episode 300 of how I met your mother.
I have a piece of,
have a pizza box there with one slice,
with one bite out of it.
And maybe I was drinking like a protein shake or something,
you know,
cause I had to hide.
You gotta hydrate Bro.
You gotta hydrate and so,
and get,
she'd show up with a six pack of Gatorade and a Alpha brain or like another
generic a nootropic cause I was the thing,
I was like,
oh,
as long as I got my new tropics.
Yeah.
But,
um,
and so that's three days.
And because I wasn't wearing my legs,
I literally sat on the couch,
like,
look at my posture right now.
This is from sitting on the couch for like a year straight.
Like I gotta like work now,
you know,
and I,
uh,
and yeah,
man,
you just,
some of your behavior is inexplainable and I'll tell you right now,
I did some be some behavior that I'm just like,
you know,
I don't know.
It's a,
it's a literal fall.
And then I wasn't evil or anything,
but I was not a good guy.
I was not a good guy.
I'm lucky to have her next to me.
I'm lucky to have that.
My kids still talk to me.
I'm lucky my mom didn't disown me,
you know?
Um,
I know at the end of the day they all came together and I,
I sucked it up.
I manned up,
I took ownership and I went to rehab and I threw my,
I did what I did in my book,
you know,
left that line where I say I went back to training.
Like I got sent him as punishment.
I got sent back to the battle school and I had a choice.
I could be the asshole that I was the first time or I could show up in shape
with my boots polished and my uniform Ireland and be the best candidate and a
soldier that I could be.
And I did that and I,
he went to Rehab and I did that.
And within 30 days they were offering me a job.
I got one more question about that,
but the bottom,
so you,
you basically,
this happens for three,
for three days,
you buy enough cocaine for three days and then you're watching TV,
you're eating pizza,
you're sitting around,
you're just in a bad place.
Then you run out of cocaine.
And then when you are not high anymore from the cocaine,
are you like,
okay,
I just want to get more cocaine.
Is that basically what happens?
Um,
usually you go through a period of self loathing.
Okay.
I was going to say,
help me point when you,
when you,
when you sober up and you go,
Dang,
why,
why am I doing this?
Like a lot.
But also it's a joke in the community are those that enjoy that partake because
it's called the cocaine blues because your system has been hijacked and
hardwired and been,
it's Kinda like when you nitrous your engine,
right?
And you just nitrous it until it red lines.
Uh,
eventually there's nothing left.
So that's what happens as soon as you like let the nitrous out the,
the engine kind of like it goes,
it has no power for a while and until it cools off.
And that's basically what you go through.
And the only way to remedy if less you power through the three to three to three
days or the week,
depending on how long your binge was till your serotonin levels come back and it
takes,
it can take,
and I,
at this point I was abusing for a year,
right?
Like steady.
Well,
actually by the end of last year,
it was two years steady state,
2017,
2018 are basically a write off for me.
As much as I got certain things done,
a lot of it was a write off,
but you,
you go through,
as soon as it's done,
you're like,
I'm never doing this again.
Oh my God,
I can't,
you call,
I'd call her and I'd be like,
I'm sorry.
I can't believe I did it.
She'd be like,
all right,
well I've heard that before.
You know,
at first it was optimism.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
we'll work on this together.
And then,
but then you know what?
And then like I said,
you know,
remember when I said an inch off your as as a myth or whatever.
Now it's like a millimeter and you're like,
all right.
And unfortunately the guy delivers,
you know,
so you don't even have to get,
you don't even have to get dressed.
He just come to the door and like,
you know,
and then put it on my tab and uh,
and yeah,
and even when and when that guy says,
are you sure that's another indication?
Like,
wouldn't the guy who makes money off you being an idiot thinks you're an idiot?
You got to start thinking about life choices.
And you know,
I did it.
I went through it,
man.
[inaudible] again,
I'm here to tell the truth.
You and the listeners,
because they're watchers,
if they're on youtube,
like I can't hide it and to,
to,
to pretend I just had some issues like a lot of people,
uh,
you hear in the media,
right?
Oh,
there they're having some issues.
Just say what it is,
man.
It's just what,
as soon as I went on the,
uh,
show in Ottawa,
the same guy who,
who came to me and I,
and I did the,
and I,
and I went on a show and I said it,
I said I did cocaine.
It felt like a thousand pounds man off my shoulders.
And he's,
he's like,
I did not expect that.
I said,
I know,
man.
And that's how much of a bullshit artist I became an eye.
And I hate it.
I hate it.
My ex even said once,
she said you weren't,
you weren't a sneaky bullshitter before,
you know,
like you gotta stop this.
And you know,
it's the extreme ownership comes in here because
even when I,
you know,
when I first back 20 years ago when I first got sent back to training as
punishment for being an idiot,
I owned it.
Anyone say,
Hey,
are you the guy who got arrested for coke?
I'd be like,
well I didn't have it but,
but yeah,
yeah that was me.
Because what are you gonna do?
Say No.
Like,
you know,
and,
and I always tried to live that way and I lost myself to this stuff and I,
this has stopped being honest with everyone,
especially myself.
And that's saying that you got to look after yourself before you can look after
anybody else's is a 150% true.
You know,
even,
and Kelly's even learned some lessons here cause she didn't take enough time to
recover from her surgery and it almost killed her again.
You know,
and she,
because she was worried about that at work and her kids and this,
you got to worry about yourself.
And um,
and again,
man,
I'm on like a redemption to her almost.
I feel like I,
and I love it.
I love it.
Like we were,
we,
where were we?
I forgot where we were,
but you know,
somebody said something and I went,
Oh yeah,
I just got out of Rehab for cocaine.
And they went,
oh,
okay.
Uh,
so coffee,
cause I think they wanted to get a drink and I'm like,
yeah,
I just got to rehab,
you know,
it's a great conversation starter or ender.
So talk to me about Rehab.
What,
what goes on there?
You know,
it's a,
it's a whole lot of just being told to think about how you're living your life.
Um,
I did mow usually for cocaine,
they want 90 days.
I was only willing to commit to 30 because I still had a little bit of like that
ego going and stuff.
Um,
and I did the 30 and I did okay.
And,
uh,
like I said,
they were offering me a job or like,
you know,
we were in talks about maybe working there.
Um,
but you know,
it's funny how like once you open your mind to possibilities,
this the way forward is,
is obvious.
I have no business being in this town called Brockville where the rehab place
was.
Um,
but if I wasn't there,
Kelly and I wouldn't have found this building that when I was sending you where,
which inspired us to remind us that two years ago when we first moved out of our
house or three years ago now,
holy crap,
almost three years ago now,
when we first moved out from our old relationships and we're trying to establish
her own,
um,
my goal before I got elected was I wanted to open a gym and I wanted to build a
community of positive people and I wanted to like wake up every morning,
have a coffee.
Like,
I don't know why,
but in my mind I have an image of me in shorts with a long sleeve tee shirt
opening up like a garage door and having like people come in with gym bags like,
Hey Jody,
how's it going?
Good morning sir.
You don't like and not stare like hey sir,
but like,
cause I'm like,
I'm like the leader or like I'm the,
I'm the papa bear of this group.
That's what we,
Kelly and I call it has those Mama and papa bear and will even in Rehab they
started calling me papa bear.
Cause I'd be like,
I was almost twice as old as most of the people there.
Um,
most of them were like late teens,
early twenties,
maybe 30.
Some of them were 30.
But you know,
even the older people like there was like one woman,
they're in their sixties and she'd be like,
Hey papa bear,
because that's just who we are.
Like I like,
you're the same,
you're like me,
but like and Kelly's this,
we just,
we want to look after people.
We can't help it.
Right.
You know,
and the Rehab people will look after yourself.
But anyway,
Kelly comes and picks me up and I'm alive.
I can give an a day pass,
you know that go,
they let you go vote for the day.
If you're good,
if you're good boy echo,
they let you go out on Rehab.
And so we're driving around.
That's when I saw that building.
I think I sent you picked your duty the next,
yeah,
1905 this thing was a windmill,
a beautiful big wooden beams,
like a beautiful building.
Unfortunately it would have been more to repair it than it would have been to
buy it,
but it put our minds on this path to what a great area that is.
The fact that we want to go back on this path of building this community.
And so we want to build.
So we're still doing it every and,
and,
and we,
you should,
you should hit Kelly and I drive a lot because we have our best meetings are
business meetings or when we're driving and,
and so we want to open what's called Hq and it's going to be a fitness wellness
center.
And,
um,
and it's going to be more of a community than anything.
Kind of like if you want to just come chill,
you can come chill.
We're going to have,
I want to have a library,
I want to have a podcast studio,
I want to have classrooms and you know,
and we're going to just like be there to help you live a better life.
And,
uh,
and the best way for me to live a good life is to help you live a good life.
And I've realized that now,
like even when I was in my military unit,
like,
um,
even if I wasn't hungry,
I'd grab extra food and bring it back to the boys.
You know,
if I,
if I realize like there was something shiny around to be had,
I'd like find a way to get my hands on it for the,
for the team and stuff.
You know,
I'm my happiest when I'm looking out for others and I know,
and at the same time though,
you know,
they're looking out for you and it feels good to have friends and family and,
and you know,
a tribe around you.
Right.
You know,
we're tribal animals and I,
you know,
do you know Tait Fletcher?
He was Joe Rogan Buddy.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
well,
I don't know him personally.
So I met,
I met Tate in 2013 when I did a piece for vice,
uh,
at the University of Southern California about how they do virtual reality to
treat PTSD.
It's on motherboard,
if you want to Google it and go ahead.
I mean,
I look pretty cool in it,
but anyway,
um,
so Tate,
I was down here and I had met Tate when I was here.
I did his podcast and in this,
and you know,
so this is going back six or seven years.
And,
um,
I've never met Rogan,
but I mean eventually I might,
I mean I know enough people that know him.
But anyway,
the point is I was driving around with Tate and uh,
we're here in California to do a course at Deuce gym in La,
uh,
which Tate introduced me to the owner of,
and this guy has just such a cool dude and he rents such a nice gym and the
atmosphere.
So we're going to take his seminar.
And I,
and I said,
man,
I wish I had what you have here in California,
any and Tate,
this was a mine chain or a life changing moment and I had to go through all of
this to get here.
He said,
build it.
And I said,
ah,
what?
He said,
if you want it,
build it.
And I said,
okay.
And it's taken me since 2013 to get back to here and go through all these other
things to realize like,
ah,
I got to build it.
That's why knock going into politics again means I can do whatever I want.
Like you said,
man,
like you're right.
Like it's tough.
Like it's,
there's moments of great happiness and politics,
but unless that's what you want to do,
like it's hard.
It's very hard and guys like us,
we're self motivated to do things and waiting around for others to do their
thing and it's just easier to do your own thing,
you know?
Uh,
especially,
you know,
like what's,
I know he was a German,
but in world war two,
his,
his orders were finding an objective and kill it.
That was his orders at all times.
Like if you don't hear from me,
find something and destroy it.
That's basically the mission statement that Kelly and I have put before.
So I was like,
we want to build this place,
build a community and live a good life.
And I never want to be,
the guy was for the last two years.
And uh,
but I want to say glad,
but it's an experience that I've learned a lot from.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
it does make sense.
It does make sense.
It's sort of like the thing I told the Sam Harris when he,
when he was telling me that it's hypocritical for me because I say war is
horrible and awful,
but I always say it's the best experience of my life.
And he says,
hypocritical for that.
And then,
well,
rightfully so,
you can't say something's awesome and then say it's horrible.
And I said,
well,
it's like this.
And I asked him if he had ever known anyone that had had cancer and survived and
he said yes.
And I said,
a lot of those people say I'm glad it happened because they get this different
perspective of life and different perspective of the world and different value
of life and different value of the world.
And so even though you wouldn't wish it on somebody,
you're happy that you had to go through it.
And so I,
that sounds like a similar situation.
I always tell people I had a great time at war right up to the last step because
it's a horrible thing to do.
But it's what I trained.
I volunteered to be there.
You volunteered to be there.
Like,
I always say,
you know,
people could be,
a lot of people say they're sorry for me losing my feet.
And I say,
you know,
if I was a Russian drafty and Afghanistan,
yeah.
Be or feel sorry for me,
but I've,
I was exactly where I want it to be,
you know?
And uh,
and the fact that one of my boys didn't die because I stepped on that,
you know,
like the,
if the,
like I said,
if the guy in front of me had stepped on it,
I'd be dead.
If the guy in front of him had stepped down and he'd be dead and I'd be like,
we don't know.
Um,
I'm glad I was the one that stepped on it.
But yeah.
Like I love doing my job.
It was a great,
it was an,
it was an amazing job,
you know,
been the people that you're around or some of the greatest human beings you're
ever going to know on the planet,
you know?
Um,
so that's what I want to rebuild.
I want to rebuild this brotherhood and the sisterhood,
this community of,
of,
of likeminded individuals and the saying,
surround yourself with people that make you better.
That's not what happens when you're on cocaine.
So,
so at some point you went from this mindset of you could see where the future
was,
you could see the cocaine is going to ruin your future and you didn't care.
And at some point during this,
you said to yourself,
okay,
I see the future with cocaine.
It's terrible and I'm not going to go there.
Yeah,
well it was,
it was life without Kelly.
It was life without the kids.
It was life without real friends.
Uh,
you know,
like even people that love you to death can't be around you because you know,
you're just not assist.
It's one,
it's hard,
you know,
and I've,
I've had a few buddies go down and it mostly booze,
like boozes that most common one because it's rarely available there.
Go down to the store and get it for some reason.
Um,
you know,
like,
listen,
I get a lot of flack but I'm a fan of the,
and I know safe injection site is like,
people don't agree with,
there's no such thing as safe injection.
Okay,
I get it.
But the point is I'm forgiving the option of a place that's safer than a
dumpster to shoot up with heroin if it means we might save that life.
Right.
And I'm also like,
we've visited Canada federally,
we legalize marijuana.
Um,
if it was up to me,
anything people want would be regulated,
taxed and taxed,
right?
Because,
um,
if a bottle of Jack Daniels,
Hertz,
Hertz Echo,
if he drinks it or hurt,
like if it hurts us,
there's someone who can be held accountable and we can trace that right down to
the barrel that it was brewed in or made,
I dunno how whiskey is fermented,
distill,
there's the word.
Whereas if a guy shoots up behind a dumpster and dies,
I don't know who to go after and who to like,
whose fault is it that it was a bad product or a good product,
which is usually what gives them an overdose.
But you know,
like there's just,
um,
the past too,
you know,
like Aa is there because we can get booze at every corner,
and so we have gambling sites.
If you go into a casino,
you're actually warned on the door,
like a pack of cigarettes says if you smoke this,
it will be addictive and it could hurt you.
I just think we need to start talking more about things.
And so for me,
like,
you know,
I don't like,
I don't know,
man.
I just,
I saw that I wouldn't have the good things in life because of this one thing
that had taken over.
And I,
my cousin actually,
uh,
in 28,
2017 and 2017,
my cousin who I grew up with killed himself,
not with,
and I don't mean killed himself as in like committed suicide.
And he just drugged himself to death and he was addicted to,
it was addictive.
He was addicted to it and we never,
I never figured it out and I had to stop hanging out with them.
And that was what was happening to me too.
My,
we call her,
you know,
whether you think it's weird or Fufu or whatever you want to call it.
We do Kelly and I do believe we're soul mates and that's weird.
And frou Frou yes,
but you can do it.
Yeah.
Well thank you.
Right.
And that's the thing.
So if you're,
if the person who you think you were put on the planet to be with says,
I can't be with you the way you are,
that's hey man.
Like you got to take a serious look.
And so it sounds like that really was the critical thought in your head that the
person that you cared the most about at this moment in time is literally going
to walk away.
She had can't push it away.
I saw it.
I was like,
I had to go to rehab to give her a break and to give my kids a break.
When you went to Rehab,
did you say to yourself,
I'm going there.
Did you go in there with the attitude of not Polish your boots and be the best
soldier?
You can bet.
If I didn't finish that.
Sorry.
I have an Adhd.
If he can't tell.
But,
um,
I went in there polished boots,
pressed uniform.
I like,
I had my books,
I made my bed.
It was all the basics.
Get back to the basics,
right.
We even talked about this the first time I was on your show.
I shaved my head.
I started doing some,
you know,
started working out a little bit,
trying to get back into the little bit of shape.
I started caring about what I ate again.
I started taking my vitamins.
I started,
you know,
when I went in there and I know exactly what I'm like when I want to portray
that tough guy attitude.
And that's what I did to keep people away at first because at first ever been
arrested?
Yes.
Where you've happy?
We happy about it.
No.
Yeah.
So I kind of went in like I'd been arrested like I was the first time,
not the second time that is in the book,
but the first,
anyway.
Um,
like I said,
I don't put everything in the book,
but anyway,
you're not very happy and you don't need friends.
So I didn't go in there to make friends.
So I was a,
I was like a wall for the first week.
Right.
But that let me concentrate on exactly what I was there to do,
if that makes sense.
And so as that,
as,
as I was there to get better and do Rehab got,
I don't want to say easier,
but I got better at it cause it's,
you know,
it's a skill that you are actually taught in rehab is how to be better.
That's what Rehab is there teaching you how to be better again.
So like what,
what kind of skills are they teaching?
Wake up on time.
I know it sounds weird,
but like,
you know,
when you're addicted,
it doesn't sound weird to me.
It's like basic training,
almost make,
get up,
make your bed,
you know,
come to breakfast on time.
So if you weren't at breakfast,
you lost your ability to make a phone call that night.
And then have you missed any classes during the day,
you know,
you'd have privileges,
given or taken as as the day or the week went by.
Now you're,
you're,
you're at a place where you pay money to go,
so you'd think it'd be,
how do you take privileges from someone?
But they do,
they do.
I was like,
I'm a grown ass man.
If I want to make a phone call,
I bill.
They're like,
no you won't.
I'm like,
God damn it,
you're right.
Because I signed that waiver,
but I,
I've tried so hard that I got to,
like,
they were bringing me in,
you know,
I'm not,
I anyway,
I should probably shouldn't say too much,
but like within,
you know,
I was only there 30 days,
but within about,
I'd say 15,
20 days,
I was someone that was turned to buy the other clients and someone that some of
the staff would turn to,
to like for backup in a certain situation.
Or like I said,
I went papa bear and,
but when I first got there,
some of the other clients told me,
like when I got there,
they were like,
this guy is a murderer.
He's going to kill us all.
Like,
cause I was just so focused and I had this look on I,
you know,
I know,
we're,
we get up in front of troops and try to,
you know,
we gotta be the toughest looking high there.
Some of them,
you know,
and so I know how to do it.
But I did that too for myself more than anything because I went,
okay,
I'm back in basic training,
I have to learn how to be a decent human being and how to look after myself
again and man,
and they took you through check checklists.
A lot of,
a lot of my personality flaws stem from childhood,
you know,
and I found that out.
Like what?
Like stuff I don't want to talk about frankly.
And you know,
just things that once you read the literature it's,
oh,
that is obvious.
So you can,
you can,
and this is a conversation that we've been hard at and I didn't mean to be so
abrupt.
I'm not,
I'm not sure it's fine.
But what I mean is I now understand,
and that's for me understanding like most guys like us and girls,
if I understand the cause,
I can,
I can deal with the action.
Right?
So,
but if you don't understand that it's just chaos.
But if there is an explanation as to why my mind goes there,
which then causes me these actions,
ah,
now I can go back and deal with the cause of that behavior.
Does that mean,
is that a better way of putting it?
Yeah,
no it does.
It does make sense.
And this is something that I just talked about on another podcast,
but the first time I kind of recognize that there was these patterns in
protocols for a psychological issues is honestly when Jordan Peterson came on
for the first time and he was,
I was explaining how in the warrior kid book,
how the kid gets over the fear of the water and he goes,
oh yeah,
that's a,
that's a protocol.
It's called exposure therapy.
And this is what I've done,
psychological,
this is how it works.
And I just figured that out from just life,
right?
Yeah.
And then I realized that the,
that there's protocols for problems and people have psychological problems.
There's a pro and it's just an a,
and I was using the term brain mechanic,
but somebody on Twitter said something better,
which is mind mechanic.
So if I would've been told,
hey,
oh,
psychologist and a psychologist,
they're called a mind mechanic and they go in there and when there's problems,
they know how to fix those problems.
I love that.
Yeah.
AndW but when you're well like me,
you're just thinking,
oh,
that's just a bunch of,
what'd you say earlier?
Fufu something Hippie dippy.
Yeah.
It's a bunch of hippy dippy stuff that you don't really know what's going on,
but then you talk to or,
or in talking to Jordan,
I heard him say,
oh,
and this is a problem that you would see and this is how you'd fix that problem.
Here's another problem over here and here's how you'd fix that problem.
And the really strange thing is it all lined up with just my natural instincts
when somebody had this kind of problem.
And be like,
okay,
here's what you need to do.
In that scenario.
I would just know that from dealing with a bunch of guys over the past 30 years
that were having issues and be like,
hey man,
oh,
you got this problem,
here's what you need to do,
move,
do this,
do that.
But a psychologist,
a mind mechanic can look at and go,
here's what's going on,
here's what this root ties into and here's how you stop this,
this cycle of negativity and how you move it in a positive direction yet.
And that's exactly what Rehab is.
It's let's find the co like you're not a bad person for having these thoughts
and actions and reactions because you know,
and that's,
and then,
oh,
here's why.
Oh,
okay.
Here's where the pattern developed when you were like five or 10 or then this
happened and your buddy that we were talking about before the show,
uh,
Jay Redmond yet honestly,
I'd love to talk to them because it sounds like him and I probably had very
similar childhoods.
And then similar careers,
you guys definitely had similar careers for the fact that you got sent back to
whatever that title school battle school and Jay read me God sent to ranger
school,
you know,
and then it's,
it's very,
you guys definitely had some similar,
I think I was a little more humble than him from the sounds of it,
but I'm just,
I don't know,
but I,
but I was still owed,
like
I almost got kicked out of snipers for being arrogant.
It's,
it's a close race.
And it was because I didn't say,
uh,
I said Sir to the sergeant major instead of calling him by his first name,
cause he liked to be called by his first name by the snipers.
Cause then it showed he was bros with us.
Yeah.
Whatever.
I'll see.
Am I showing my arrogance?
Maybe right now?
Yes.
Yeah.
No,
but it's,
but that's the thing is Jay Redmond,
you know,
he went through all that and his book is phenomenal because I'd love to read
this,
comes right out and explains all these mistakes that he made and he did a great
job,
redeem,
noose off and turn it into a great,
great frogmen.
And that's what I wanted and that's my job,
my book.
Unflinching it wasn't a let's make Jody,
you look like a hero.
It was like,
let's be honest and clear about how,
you know,
you start one one's place and ended up in another,
but you have to,
you know,
you have to realize that mistakes happen and you know,
being 40,
you know,
and by,
by 42 as a kid,
I thought I'd have it all together,
but uh,
you know,
I'm still learning.
I'm still,
you know,
like a,
I call myself a student,
a student of the human condition because I feel like I'm always learning and I
will never,
no one's ever an expert on anything.
I don't think.
And if you click can think you are,
it means you've stopped learning in my opinion.
I don't know.
I know we're going a little off.
What are the withdrawal?
How bad is the withdraw from?
Because I know,
you know,
I think the only thing that you not supposed to withdraw on your own is alcohol
cause you can actually die if you're an alcohol addict and you stop cold Turkey.
Yeah,
you can.
If you're shy,
if you're deep into it,
you can have,
um,
I quit oxycotton cold Turkey and when I told my doctor,
he said I coulda had seizures and stuff and could have died,
but it wasn't on that high dose then either.
So it's um,
what about when you quit drinking?
I didn't do well.
Not that big of a deal.
Yeah,
the alcohol,
you got to drink a lot,
a lot to be in that situation.
Like these guys who were like drinking the whole bottle of vodka every day.
You don't ever see that movie leaving Las Vegas with Nic Cage?
No.
Like that guy.
Like he would go grocery shopping and his car every day in his cart was full of
booze.
That's,
which is actually more common than I thought.
Oh Bro.
It's crazy.
Some guys get after it with a,
with a bug and their vodka for some reason cause they think you can't smell it.
Yeah.
But I mean if you drink enough you can smell it.
Uh,
but uh,
but the withdrawals were,
is it,
is it mostly psychological?
Yeah,
big time psychological.
Uh,
there's some physical at first.
Um,
your boss,
I went through a period where my body was like detoxing.
So like I was getting these weird zits on in like weird places and stuff like
that.
And,
and um,
uh,
is this from the cocaine?
Yeah,
it's from the impurities that they get mixed with.
Right.
But then as far as detox or you're talking about detox and from cocaine?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Sorry.
Um,
yeah,
but I mean it's more just like letting your brain re level re level itself.
So I went in there,
I stopped taking any Tylenol,
like I don't take,
I'm trying to,
and I,
Kelly and I are working on this.
We're trying to get,
like,
we're almost sugars,
almost gone.
Uh,
I,
I don't take any pills or I keep going away from the mic.
Um,
where,
where are we babe?
I,
we were in West Virginia doing some training or not training.
We were doing some familiarization at a place,
uh,
built for three letter agencies.
And um,
my,
my leg was just on fire because of the day we'd had and she gave me two Tylenol
and to leave and I,
I passed out like,
like that I could,
I didn't know that was in the morning.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I fell back to sleep cause I woke up with the pain anyway.
Uh,
that's what I want.
I remember the first time I took a Tylenol and I was in,
cause after I joined the army and we're on exercise maybe a year later and I was
in the woods and my back was a little sore so the medic gave me two extra
strength.
Tylenol.
I just never had Tylenol before cause I just,
I,
you know,
I was 17,
18 and I took it and my body felt like it was on Unicorns and sunshine for like
three days.
And that was from two extra strength Tylenol.
When you're doing blow and,
and drinking a lot,
like your breakfast,
you know,
to get over it.
And,
and I like that if I take one Tylenol now my body's okay.
You know,
cause I'm a big guy,
so I need,
you know,
I usually go extra strength.
I wanna,
I wanna be able to take regular strengths.
Remember that everybody took regular strength,
anything.
Um,
you know,
I have a coffee and I feel it.
It's not just like a whatever anymore.
Um,
so that's kind of what I'm on a bit of a mission to get back to really basic
food and liquid intake.
Um,
you like the cold brew
that I was drinking and when we got here,
like there's nothing else in it.
It's just coffee,
eh,
that had the nitrogen in it.
Right?
But there's no sugar in Oak.
You know,
I'll put a little cream in my coffee now.
Um,
instead of extra larges.
Right.
We're trying to unbind mediums and small,
so we're trying to just get,
get back down to a baseline of,
of a,
of minimum.
And uh,
it's working okay.
But you know,
it's a daily,
I talked to my rehab guy at least once a week still.
Um,
you know,
I sent him pictures of our travels and stuff,
we got the dog,
I got the service dog now does this lake,
you know,
they're so busy,
like she's such a,
she's a German shepherd malinois mix.
There's such busy dogs that like you just,
you don't have time to,
to,
to be hung over or anything.
So,
and um,
like you could drink it on your own anyway,
right?
Like you're like as long time ago.
Well,
yeah.
So what happened with me is I just retired from the navy and,
and while while I was in the navy was pretty normal tubes to drain can,
we've talked to him.
But when I retired,
I just looked up a month later and it hadn't had anything to drink that I looked
up three months later and I hadn't had anything to drink that I looked up six
months later and I was like,
man,
I have no desire now.
And I must say,
you know,
you talked about how not having an addictive personality,
and I think I truly do not have an addictive personality.
I think that other than maybe like something like Jujitsu or something like
that,
which I definitely got pretty fanatic about and I still have a hard time with
withdrawals if I don't get to train for a certain amount of time.
What did dean say?
You're the,
Oh yeah.
And Dean lister one time said I was addicted to power.
So domination.
Yeah.
You know,
I was,
I was giving him a hard time about not training and hassling him and telling me,
you know,
you're,
you're just addicted to that now.
And he said,
you're an addict,
you're an addict too.
And I said,
what am I addicted to?
And he says,
you're,
you're addicted to power,
but a,
Eh,
if you can do it on the,
and the,
on the mats better than becoming like a dictator or something.
But the point is for me is when I,
I,
I never even like I would see maybe in my mid twenties I would get fired up
like,
hey,
like my platoon,
it would be the end,
it would be a Friday.
And we just got done with some hard training and we were in some random city and
it'd be like,
Oh yeah,
we're going to go on and have a good time tonight.
And it was more about like,
Hey,
I know we're not going to have a good time about tonight.
Did it was like,
I really need a beer.
Yeah,
me too.
And so as I did that,
that was just kind of normal and there was definitely,
the problem with that attitude is there are people that have addictive
personalities in alcohol,
has ruined all kinds of guys in the seal teams and all kinds of guys in the
military because it's really,
it's just a slippery slope to go from,
Oh,
and this is just normal to,
hey,
it's Tuesday night,
I'm at home,
I'm alone and I'm going to drink a 12 pack.
That's a pretty Slippy slippery slope that people,
people get through.
Actually just having Jason Gardner on and he,
he was,
he quit drinking just like maybe,
I don't know,
a couple months ago.
Yeah.
But you know,
I said,
well,
how much were you drinking?
He goes,
you know,
and I'd come home and I'd crack one open and then I'd crack one open before
dinner and then I'd have one during dinner.
Then I'll have one after dinner and then maybe we'd have one before I go to bed.
Well,
there's six beers and he's not a big guy.
So six beers is like,
you know,
he's good.
And he's even said like,
oh,
I would feel it,
you know,
not feel it.
Like,
you know,
he's still doing everything he has to,
but he's not doing it optimally.
And now he said he could sick.
I feel just amazing that,
that,
and that's pretty much how Jason talks.
So he says,
I feel amazing now,
but he's one of those guys that,
you know,
you could go down that slippery slope and he wasn't far down it,
but he would look up every night and call,
you know,
cause when you wake up,
let's face it,
you ever six beers,
you don't feel as good as if you had no beers.
And that's something you talked about that go,
yeah,
I remember that you were talking about drinking too much vodka or something
fully.
Yeah.
Next day you feel like the brakes,
the thing,
like you wake up and you feel foggy and like,
you know,
like three days are wasted if you do too much.
Any of anything,
you know,
like you could,
who knows?
But,
um,
to put,
you know,
I knew guys that woke up and drank whiskey with breakfast,
but it was so accepted in our world as well that it was,
you know,
if you showed up for PT and you were hung over,
it was a joke,
right?
Yeah.
What's up Jodie?
You,
it feels,
it was a badge of honor.
It was a badge of honor.
Like,
Oh yeah,
this guy's drunk.
Wow.
Look at how well this guy can run.
Even though he's hammered running,
even though he's like throwing up on the moves.
That's soldier right there.
There's an old seal master chief at seal team one before I got there and old
Vietnam guy and when you went in and talked to him,
he would pour shots of Tequila.
That's how it was going to be like,
oh,
it's nine o'clock in the morning.
Cool.
You want to talk to me?
Roger that school in shots,
old school and that's again,
there's people that can handle that and there's people that can't and broadly
speaking,
let's face it,
and this is what I eventually thought to myself.
Broadly speaking,
it made no,
it makes no sense whatsoever to me.
Now as I look back,
I'm like,
this makes no sense to me.
This does absolutely nothing positive for me.
It doesn't make me stronger.
It doesn't make me smarter.
In fact,
it does.
The opposite makes you weaker and makes you dumber.
But it took me a long time to figure that out.
And weird thing for me is when I was a kid growing up,
I was into hardcore music and like the straight edge scene of people,
not the x is on your hand.
I didn't actually have that,
but uh,
but I definitely listened to that music and it was,
it,
it had an influence on me without a doubt had an influence on me because it was,
it was,
it was a rebellion in account or to the kids that I knew that were getting drunk
and acting stupid and smoking pot and I'm over here going literally thinking
you're weak and I'm strong.
Yeah.
That's an arrogant thing to say.
But that's as a,
as a 14 1516
year old kid when you're looking at someone else that's smoking pot and getting
drunk and you're thinking they're weak and I'm strong.
That's kind of a positive thing as far as I'm concerned.
Yeah.
I remember getting called week when I didn't drink in the platoon.
Oh,
a hundred percent out.
But I grew up both sides of the family have their fair share of alcoholics.
Um,
even even as a kid,
I was someone who,
you know,
even though I'm Canadian,
a Nancy Reagan say no to drugs worked.
Uh,
like I said,
I smoked hash a handful of times cause my buddy's mom was hot and she sold it.
And um,
you know,
and then I didn't,
I didn't touch anything except booze.
And even then it was like,
I was like,
you,
I could go three months and not drink and just be like,
I haven't had a drink for like three months.
You know,
I quit cigarettes when we're on deployment because I couldn't run up the hill
next to the,
to our camp.
I was like,
fuck,
if I can't run up the hill,
obviously these things.
And I was just something I picked up as a,
cause I watched lethal weapon too much.
Yeah,
right.
Mel Gibson.
Oh,
and then,
and then Bruce Willis,
Bruce Willis and Mel Gibson,
all they did with smoking,
their movies still smoke in movies right now.
Let go Charles a cutaway less way less.
Yeah,
I was watching that movie,
Constantine with Ken or eaves last night.
I just,
one of my favorite movies.
I Dunno.
Why Demons and devils.
I don't know.
I just liked that one.
But uh,
he smokes a lot,
but that's the character.
He dies a lung cancer and that,
that's part of the actual plot.
Yeah,
he actually has,
it actually has lung cancer in the movie anyway.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
but I and I and the guy who told me about this anti addictive personality,
like in my twenties so I kind of skated on that.
You felt like that was more reinforcement for your personality but also like I
quit smoking and drinking,
honestly,
dude,
like it,
I said it was a problem because at the time it was,
but it was because I was doing all the coke cause and it levels you and I could
drink on New Year's Eve a Kell,
like she was like,
I don't want to drink anymore,
but it helps you to not do coke.
And I was like,
all right,
awesome.
So we quit drinking,
but that the cocaine just wouldn't let go.
And again,
I'd go through like a week where I wouldn't do it and then had a week where I
did it and then,
you know,
but eventually,
like you said,
your buddy,
you didn't hit his bottom wasn't they gave bottom,
you know what I was thinking about,
uh,
your bottom is whatever you want it to be.
And uh,
and so I,
I saw the bottom coming for,
for the whole,
for like the whole time,
pretty much 2017.
I didn't for a lot of it,
uh,
but near the end it was,
it was clear that there was a problem.
Like I still didn't really see the problem until I was doing those interviews.
And then right before I saw you,
but then 2018,
it was trying to level out and figure out which way was up,
which are,
it was down again,
you know,
and,
uh,
you know,
don't be afraid to call in reinforcements like we talked about last time.
Like,
no,
no one is a rock.
No one's an island.
Right.
Like you don't like Rambo to isn't real.
As,
as cool as a movie character.
He is.
Um,
he has air support.
He has,
you know,
he has a fire team.
He has a,
he has that machine gun team on the flank.
He's got,
you know,
he's got,
uh,
indirect on it.
Standby.
Like no one is a one man army.
And you know,
and I,
I talked about this last time and I talked about it the first time I was on the
show and I keep relearning these things,
but in different contexts.
And,
you know,
I'm,
I hope I'm done learning,
uh,
these,
these lessons.
Um,
you know,
uh,
and I want to get back to just live in positive,
clean.
Um,
you know,
I've,
I'm repeating myself now,
but dude,
like it was rough and I honestly,
I questioned whether or not like,
you know,
like people like you or people,
uh,
in Canada,
there's some of my friends,
like,
are they going to accept what I'm dishonest.
But I was prepared for the consequences too because that's,
I felt like what I deserved with my actions.
Does that make sense?
Okay.
And,
and,
uh,
for the most part,
like I said,
everyone's been understanding like,
and it makes it easier for me to talk about,
you know,
one of the reasons I,
I've,
I've talked with about with my psychologist,
why I didn't get PTSD from my injuries is cause I talked about it so much.
So I'm hoping that talking about this openly and if,
if,
if more listeners to the show and you know,
um,
if you go to my show to Jody Mitic podcast,
episode 39,
I believe is full disclosure,
where I tried to,
I tried to lay it all out even more than we have here.
Um,
and it feels better every time I tell the story,
you know,
and it's a lot to get into like an hour or two.
It is really,
but,
you know,
with us,
it's almost like an evolution,
right?
The first show we did good.
But you know,
even back then,
like if things were,
things were getting to be a little dicey with the politics and the home life and
stuff.
But,
and man,
I,
I just,
and you know,
I did go through a period where losing my legs became a real problem there in
Kelly's nodding her head because she saw it,
you know,
like when I couldn't wear my legs,
I couldn't drive my car.
I know I drove here last time,
but I had with the hand controls when I first took the legs off that I didn't
have that I was in an apartment by myself.
Um,
you know,
and anyway,
I just,
you know,
uh,
here I am.
Do you,
you know,
the dog's coming up cause you can feel,
I'm getting a little worked up right now.
How hard day to day
are you thinking to yourself?
Like what's the temptations level daily where you have your friend that delivers
of,
right.
Right now none.
So how hard is it on like a day to day basis?
What's the temptation like?
Um,
at first it was massive.
Like I would,
um,
you know,
that show Narcos,
I can't,
I haven't,
you know,
on,
the shoe and Argos,
it's about Pablo Escobar.
Okay.
So they just came out with season two,
which is now the Mexican cartels.
Mm.
I haven't watched a single episode.
We were watching pulp fiction and I had to turn it off when the,
what's her name did a line of coke beef when John Travolta was picking her up
like that is like I could,
I even now I avoid anything that has drugs in it for the most part.
Um,
and I,
and at first it was,
and even when I was using,
like if I was on a role where I was like two or three or four days where I
hadn't used,
if I put on a show like Scarface,
I was like,
oh you can't watch Scarface sober.
You know,
he's delivering a baller,
you know,
in a case of whiskey.
But,
um,
you know,
as time has gone by and Kelly and I are finding more positive things like HQ is
happening like I,
we call it HQ cause its headquarters for everything that we're going to do for
the future.
And we just started,
uh,
you know,
we're trying to start a home business called fire team Alpha where we're fire
team alpha.
I don't know how you guys designate in the seals,
but for us in a section you have fire team,
Alpha,
Bravo,
Charlie Delta.
Uh,
so we're fire team Alpha within the section and we want to help other couples
and individuals,
right.
And our,
our life coaching is going to involve some tactical flavor,
you know,
shooting if you want to think of that.
But,
um,
so,
you know,
like we're doing it and the closer we do it and the more steps we take,
the,
it's,
I,
you know,
we were,
last night we were driving here from La and we were like,
we were both just kind of like,
remember,
like three months ago,
it feels like forever ago.
You know,
like I remember I used to be addicted to cocaine and she's like,
what do mean used to be,
right?
Like it's a bit of a reminder,
but for me,
I don't even know that guy anymore,
you know?
But that was just me back in December.
And I liked that.
I liked that I was in rehab with people that have,
this is their fifth time and that scared the shit out of me.
I was like,
what do mean your fifth time?
And then this other guy,
you know,
and they're all in their twenties and they've been to rehab three,
four,
five,
six times.
I'm like,
damn,
I need to figure out a way to Aa and never be here again.
And B help you guys never come here again.
You know.
So we're even setting up a system with the rehab place because a,
it's a,
it's a good place if actually,
and it takes people from American candidates called Thousand Islands Rehab.
It's rate on the border where there with the Saint Lawrence.
Um,
we are working on a system where as people cause transitional housing from Rehab
to normal life is a bit of a problem.
So we are setting up,
uh,
once we have the headquarters built and everything by the end of the year,
by next year we're hoping to have like three or four bucks set up where we can
bring in likeminded people from Rehab.
You already have a building for HQ or you're working on?
We're really,
we're working on it.
Where he close.
We think we have something.
I have,
we are,
uh,
I am moving to Stittsville from Orleans in Ottawa.
That means going from the Far East end of the far west end.
Um,
we're very close.
I don't want to let the cat out of the bag in case,
uh,
like bet.
The guys that are helping me are,
are really guys I met in politics actually and they're really great guys and
they see,
you know,
they,
they've never held anything against me for what I've done.
And if anything there at 42,
it kind of sucks to be starting over again and better than the alternative.
But it's better than the alternative.
And,
you know,
I could've stayed in politics and,
and you know,
it's $110,000 a year job,
which is great and stuff.
But,
um,
I quit a job in the 90s where I as making like 65 grand a year in the nineties
as an 18 year old putting things together for Ford,
uh,
making way too much money,
stupid money for an 19 year old because I wanted to join the army and I went
from 850 bucks a week to five 20 every two weeks.
And I loved it.
And that's what Kelly and I are doing now.
We are spiritually rich and we are,
I know we want more,
we're getting greedy,
we want more in fulfillment and enrichment in our lives and we will just want to
surround ourselves with good people.
Well,
yeah.
You know,
and and you said earlier,
and I held onto the thought,
you said,
hey,
you know,
you got to take care of yourself first,
but you also,
and that's that there is definite truth to that because if you don't take care
of yourself,
you're not going to able to help anyone else.
But I'm telling you and a,
you already know,
cause this is what you're talking about.
You can take care of yourself once you got yourself under control.
There's no better reward in life than helping other people and moving people in
the right direction and helping people find the path.
So well,
I mean,
even through all these troubles we talked about right before the show,
the recruiting depot for the Canadian armed forces called me.
And I don't even think I was at a rehab yet,
was I babe?
No.
And I,
and like I said,
I wasn't shy,
but what was going on and,
and uh,
the top shot from every platoon now,
uh,
going through d through our recruitment depot is going to get the mass corporal
Jody Mitic top shot award.
There's no greater honor.
And I get to go and give a speech now to these troopers,
these young troops as they leave,
recruit bag leave there.
Now soldiers,
they've finished basic training and I get to go and tell them like,
hey,
look at me.
Look at what I did and I'm a complete fuck up.
But you know,
it's who you are on the inside.
It's how you would redeem yourself.
And it's how you look after those around you that makes you who you are.
At least that's what I think.
Look,
and here I am giving you the speech less than three months after finishing rehab
or just like three months after.
And you know what?
Hey,
as awesome as the congressional medal of honor or the Victoria Cross for me is
having something named after me that all the new troops see and some will point
at and go,
I fucking want that.
I want,
I want that award.
That's the best,
greatest honor.
The military probably could have,
uh,
bestowed on me,
you know,
to say you are someone we want our troops,
our youngest,
newest members to,
to aspire to be like,
man,
I got a job.
My job is did like to be that guy.
And,
and if,
if it means you screw up,
it means you own it and you dust yourself off and,
and you carry on.
You know,
again,
you find a way and you,
and you know what,
and that's all I'm going to keep doing.
That's why like friends like you and things like this,
podcasting in our generation is,
is how we,
how we do that.
And like,
again,
I,
I talking about it like I'm trying not to get emotional because there's a master
corporal Jody Mitic top shot award and it's not just at lake,
some unit mass hall,
you know,
like the,
what every new recruit going through.
The depot is going to see this thing and uh,
and it's anyway,
I don't know what else to say.
I'm speechless about it,
frankly.
Well,
that's awesome.
I mean,
that is,
that's just,
that's just an awesome honor that,
that these young recruits are going to come in and they're going to every single
recruit in the Canadian army.
They're going to know who you are and what you represent and part of what
they're going to see of what you represent.
Once they,
once they know your story is they're going to realize that you're not perfect
and they're going to realize that no one's perfect and they're going to realize
that they can get control over the things that have gotten out of control and
they can move forward in a positive way and make the absolute best out of what
they're doing with their life.
Like,
I don't know about you,
but like something like that puts you in a,
puts me in a position to be a mentor to these people.
Oh for sure.
It's,
and like,
same with like my,
my podcast,
you're a pot.
People come to you I'm sure out of the blue with lots of things and,
and it's it,
you know,
sometimes I,
I stopped responding for a while because of where I was,
but now I'm,
I'm getting back.
Like I wear your tee shirts again,
bro.
Like I don't know,
did we say that?
Did we say that on the,
on the air?
I'm going to,
I want one of those before I leave.
You know,
because discipline does equal freedom and it doesn't mean you govern every
moment of your day,
but it means that more disciplined you are with yourself,
the more free you are to be yourself.
Does that make more?
That's how I've always seen it.
And I've,
you know,
I feel like we're coming to a natural conclusion here.
Maybe I'm wrong,
but
thanks man.
Like both of you.
Like I just,
I,
I need people like you that guys,
I look up to you
man.
Like I know,
I know.
It's weird.
It should be the other way around it.
No,
but I do,
man.
I want that top shot award
and um,
you know,
you really,
you really helped me a lot,
you know,
and uh,
and I hope I can repay the favor one day and I,
and I know you say I don't know what yet,
but I,
I couldn't do,
I couldn't achieve what I'm doing now without the support of people like you in
my life and Echo.
Of course.
Well,
you're right,
you don't owe me anything.
And the only thing that I would like is for you to stay on the path and Roger
that moving forward and keep kicking ass and stay clean and keep doing what you
know you're capable of doing and what you're destined to do.
Good copy check.
All right.
I think that is a natural.
Can I just get a quick shout out to Warhol?
This is the ward all tee shirt.
I think it's called the dream catcher.
He's a veteran and Canada.
Go ahead and look them up in order.
Some of his t shirts help him out at full.
Is it 20?
I think 20% of his proceeds go to charity for veterans.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
Warhol,
the ward all you got like a blog and he has some cool,
cool swag was going to dude.
He's a good dude.
Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
Looking tissue.
I noticed it on the weekend.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll have him send you some check.
Um,
Echo.
Yes.
You know,
speaking of the path and whatnot,
we see it's easy to slip off the path from time to time.
It is.
We want to get back on the path if we want to stay on the path.
Recommendations.
Sure.
From Echo Charles.
Well,
I recommend Jujitsu.
So Jujitsu as a strip.
So you were talking about,
um,
what starting to judge you by the way.
I like that.
Good.
Yeah.
So relieving stress.
You will have a good time with Jujitsu.
Yeah.
I'm finally comfortable enough with my leg stumps that I feel like I can roll
with people that were feeling inadequate.
I've rolled with quite a few people with various stumps.
Yeah.
Yes.
Done.
Stumps,
stumps.
How we got Jeffrey Al here.
He's,
he's got no hand and he chokes you with that stump.
He's got a stump and he chokes you with it.
Sticks it right into your Adam's apple in position.
Part of the game.
Yeah.
That'd be good to use it.
There's people,
no hands,
no legs both.
And I'm,
I'm finally able to deal with it.
And you're below the knee too,
so you can do Somalia.
There's all kinds of stuff.
All kinds of things can go down.
Oh yeah.
So yeah,
that's a good way.
Stress Relief.
That's one of those ones that it's probably one of the biggest stress relievers
there is that I've had in my life is very,
you know,
simple.
Even right when you begin,
he gets super stressed out as we know.
Sometimes you got the dishwasher oil sauce bowls to their spot or silverware or
whatever.
That's a tough decision.
You get stressed out.
Luckily you can do the Jujitsu to relieve that.
Anyway,
I'd be stressed about the stage.
I did two a day yesterday.
I did two,
I did mornings you to afternoon,
Tuesday morning,
g evening.
Nogi what my stress level was
birthed.
It was so low.
All of this so stoked.
But that's it.
Yeah.
I did one yesterday and I went and thought,
Dang,
okay.
Avoidance.
Well,
you know things or less,
how should I say,
available as far as that Ken's,
you're working
doing various things.
There's less stress relief.
Did you get to right where that's like a double,
maybe even a triple,
actually maybe even like an endless benefit situation,
Jujitsu,
but as far as the stress,
mental stress relief.
Yes.
Yeah,
and it's,
it's soul.
You're going to like it and you actually,
you are going to hate it at first.
Jimmy get choked.
Yup.
Big Dod doctor cared for that little little hundred and 20 pound people are
gonna choke you.
They're going to get an arm lock you and you're gonna think this is not fair,
but it's not fair.
They know.
I've been like a spectator of the community for so long.
Like before I got wounded,
I want,
I might put,
my plan was to come home and actually like train and try and get a one MMA
fight.
Yeah.
Uh,
cause in Canada and like it wasn't that big a thing for 2006 and then,
you know,
the whole getting blown up thing.
But I'm fully prepared for the,
a humility that he brings because I need it frankly.
We all do.
If you look at it and since you're who you are and how you are,
you're gonna,
you're gonna have trouble avoiding the part that it's like,
yes,
this person is like beating me up in,
can you beat me up?
Even though the smaller,
so you're going to eat,
you're probably not gonna be able to avoid that element of,
of,
well,
I'm recording it.
It's a reaction.
It's a,
it's a common action reaction to what's happening.
So as long as I trained to prepare for that,
like if I train my mind,
right,
yes.
But it doesn't change that.
If Kelly chokes me out,
I will feel inadequate for a while and that's,
that's,
so there's that part,
but it was a lie.
I feel a little bit more,
yeah,
there's an eternal blessing.
I don't turn red bottle plus there.
The other part of it is if you look at it as a problem solving situation,
it's like,
okay,
he's not beating me up.
He is by the way.
But you don't think of it like that.
You think,
okay,
this is the issue.
This is a problem.
Yes,
I've got to learn how to do that.
It'll take a while.
But in any puzzle situation,
you know,
okay,
I'm not going to learn this thing overnight.
It's like huge 5,000 piece puzzle and Jujitsu.
It's infinite.
But you know,
the,
you still look at it in that sort of way and then you can start to accept,
okay.
[inaudible] thing.
I really appeals to it.
Uh,
peel that.
What appeals about it to me is that even practitioners like a,
your guys is level like Jockos level or even,
what's his name?
The guy who knows how he separated us.
Even added percent.
You're like 12 or something.
Like what's the guy,
Gracie,
even he says he learns every day and that's what I appeal.
It appeals to me because there's,
there's no true experts.
I mean there are people that will kick your ass in every day,
but they even,
they have someone that could kick.
They're always learning.
Yes.
So when you do Jujitsu,
Jody,
medic and Jocko,
you are going to need a g cause you gotta do gete and Nogi got to do both,
I think with fully stay on the path.
100% both.
So you need to g you get an origin geek.
We don't gotta ask what kind of gateway again now you know,
origin get you saw that one.
I just got you got one for me?
Yeah,
we will.
We'll get,
we'll get one 40 for sure.
Hey Roger,
that her size too.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll rock origin all day.
He's in the world straight up factually made in America.
I know you're from Canada,
but made in America actually means a lot.
Yeah.
Hey Bro,
North America where you could,
you can say made in North America,
which is also true.
I America means quality to me.
It does except for eighties cars.
These cars even then you put them back together yourself and it's just a piece
of pride that you can have in the driveway.
Your good deed and these keys are no exception by the way.
Um,
so yeah,
you got to origin main.com.
That's where you can get them.
They've got a lot of other stuff do you do to and just regular stuff,
regular life stuff.
Life stuff like jeans.
That's what I got to get you.
I've got to get some orange and jeans.
I'm a big fan of gene's a fit right.
They're legit.
And you get your supplements there,
which will keep you in the game on the path.
Hundred percent
a hundred percent a hundred percent yet that's an,
I don't really use a hundred print.
Well I do,
but do you want to say 99 just in case?
No,
no.
Normally I would say 97 you of the 1% wiggle room.
I get it.
And not,
not in this case actually,
they've proven to be the most important supplements I've ever taken.
Better than Jockos.
They are Jockos Jocko Krill oil,
Jocko joint warfare made in origin labs.
Roger that.
And we're Jen.
So you know.
Yeah,
I can see.
Okay,
now I see.
But nonetheless they are straight up.
They'll keep you in the game.
See what I'm saying?
Okay,
so discipline go,
which is a little bit of a nootropic.
Yeah,
boom.
But Jason Gardner did his first Echelon Front gig.
Nice Dang right in the game,
right in the game.
And he sent me a text and he was like,
I took this by side.
I took three discipline go 42 minutes out from the commencement.
He goes,
ty was for him.
And even tech.
It sounded like that's in the text.
He was so fired up.
But the funny thing is he texted me earlier and he says,
Hey,
it's seven o'clock in the morning.
And I was at another gig and he says,
Hey,
can you hook me up with some discipline?
Go and I said,
I'm not at my house.
My wife can get you the supply on stamps.
So this is sorta like the supply thing is like,
hey Yo,
you deliver
brie deliver.
Oh he went to my house,
picked up a couple,
picked up enough discipline for his gig discipline,
go and then he hit it.
So yeah,
if you feel like you might need a little something,
something to clarify your thoughts.
True to ignite a little bit of extra brainpower.
Yes.
Get yourself some discipline goal.
You can just get the regular discipline.
Powdered drink.
Yeah.
The thing is if you're going to be doing something where,
let's just,
let me just call it what it is.
If you're going to have to go to the bathroom and you don't want to,
like if you're going to go on stage and talk to people for two hours and then in
the middle of you get to go hard.
I even hold on a second with boost by the way.
I've never done and hopefully I never will do.
Yeah.
So that's that.
You don't know anyone even done that?
I don't know.
I mean if you ever just had to like go to the bathroom so bad when the middle of
a presentation.
Yeah,
but you don't,
no you don't.
No,
you don't let it.
Wait,
wait,
let me,
let me put it to you.
Let me read it.
Okay.
I used to before going into field hydrate like crazy.
Uh,
and,
and then so you hydrate like crazy and then you get on a helicopter and you got
to Piss and then you got like a 48 minute and as soon you're getting on the
helicopter,
you're like,
okay,
I just need it.
Should go right now and you don't cause someone's like,
hey,
come on will and get in here.
So you get in and then you're flying and you have to go to the bathroom so bad
the whole time,
the whole time and like hurt.
I've run off the Herc and job hard,
right and just passed it out because the whole flight you just,
you just made.
There are sometimes where that is really a problem.
So discipline,
go get help you out with that.
You Millennia also milk with some additional protein back in the gym or if
you're already in the gym,
whatever.
Mold,
boom.
Two.
Another two pronged effect with the milk as well.
Additional protein and dessert,
the dessert tasting delicious.
Don't forget what their warrior kid milk,
which kids everywhere are basically if you want your kid
to be just a complete destroyer on the maths in school,
in everything that they do,
get them warrior,
get mold and there'll be happy.
I went off and I had to tell a who was it?
Tyler,
you know Tyler,
the kid from origin and he's doing like the the Jocko in New York City.
Little video and I said I was going crazy.
You kind of like I just did.
And I was saying that if you don't give your kids or your kid milk,
that's child abuse.
And now I'm being real.
If you have a kid and you give your kid strawberry quick,
which is literally filled with sugar and crap or you could give them a
strawberry mold,
which tastes just as good,
if not better,
and it's 100% good for the kid.
How has that child abuse it
is not going to think about your choices.
We're going to call the uh,
the,
uh,
child protective services when we're watching,
we're seeing quick getting bought.
You're going down,
you're going to get in trouble.
So chocolate might have some disabled that chocolate and strawberry.
Yeah,
of course they do.
They're there.
They're going to pay someone and put more money into some politicians pocket to
come after me cause we're trying to make kids stronger,
bringing on world,
bring it on.
So that's that.
Jackie is also,
Jack was door,
it's called Jocko store.
And this is where we get our apparel,
right.
If you want to represent while you're on the path.
It's a good one.
Got some new stuff on there.
Lightweight hoodies.
What do you,
what do you say?
What did you see?
The UC Brady's vote and Brady's just sending,
Brady didn't even say heavyweight hoodies.
He said standard hoodies,
which I don't even want to stay in her.
Tony.
I want to heavyweight and I want to Canadian level hood.
You know what I'm saying?
Not only like standard kind of kind of.
It's too easy to be average.
Well,
Okay Brady,
I respect it.
I respect his opinion.
That wasn't just his opinion.
That was the opinion of a vote.
We'll that's winter vote all like or one of those poles a,
I get it.
And it was 60 40 in favor of standard.
If he woulda had a heavyweight on there,
it could have been a whole scenario because it opening on wellbeing.
Well good news is we already have the standard hoodies.
Okay.
And that's a good thing.
We have lightweight hoodies,
duty mimic.
What about you?
Lightweight hoodies,
Yay or nay?
Just in general.
Don't it says light weight though.
She doesn't even like that.
I just,
I want a Hoodie.
Why are you getting a Hoodie or not?
Because because people in the world exist with different,
uh,
how should I say?
Thresholds.
Different thresholds.
Different takes on the Hoodie situation rather than you and apparently genetic.
No,
Iraq.
A thin like a thin material hoodie.
Oh,
okay.
That's underneath my vest.
You're over with echo then?
Yeah.
No,
but I have another five thicker.
That's cool.
But he just said you're with me and you just said no,
no.
So you know what I'm saying?
I'm with myself here.
This is,
I got,
I have several layers of hood.
Okay,
good.
What I'm saying,
I have very thick for cold,
extreme weather and then I have very thin for,
you know,
like California.
Yeah.
See Jody is with me,
but I didn't never call it light weight.
You know what I think I just called him a Hoodie.
It's like the shirt material,
maybe slightly fic lightweight is a classification for warmth.
Okay.
So maybe call it a temperate,
temporary chapter working title,
you know,
but they are a very arid weather.
Yes,
for sure.
Used to say this thing when I'm like in the Piper incoming,
incoming,
so lightweight,
temperate hoodies,
whichever incoming two little,
anyway,
some other new stuff on there.
Anyway,
it's on Jocko store.com.
Also you can get more rash guards if you really want to represent.
So just to help out,
uh,
like a layman,
the grass guard is to avoid getting like dragged across the mats and other
people's skin.
Right.
And getting your skin's part of it.
But part of it is also you're just wearing it because if you and I are grappling
at my fingers and toes and hands and get caught and you're close and it's a
little bit of a pain,
Roger that,
okay.
It's better with the sweat situated.
Like if you're wearing this shirt,
which is cool by the way.
Oh,
if you're wearing that shirt and you sweat all in it,
you did 10 rounds,
you know,
and you're sweating all,
it's,
that's like splashing everywhere.
You know,
everything.
The rascal cotton can become a very abrasive,
uh,
when it's wet.
And as we knew new uniforms or some people wear it underneath the geese.
Some people be so you know,
if you're training geek twice a day for weeks on rash guards are a must for
training.
Jujitsu,
I will be,
once I get to know what I'm doing,
they're not a must,
but there are a nice task.
They're cool.
Yeah,
very good.
I prefer big time unless we have them.
We have some represent the path,
big time in your Jujitsu or whatever else you're doing,
cycling,
running,
whatever.
Some women's stuff on that.
Some hats on.
They're both flex fit n trucker hats.
Jody Flexner,
trucker hat.
I'm a big fan of the trucker hat because it gives me the revelation.
He liked that echo.
Yeah,
I liked that and we offer that by the way,
so winter we have winter in Canada,
so flex fit keeps the heat in the truck.
A cat because it's very humid in Ontario.
Well,
we have been these two this speaking of winter.
Oh,
okay.
There you go.
So a buckle it,
it took two,
we call it in Tuk in Canada.
He's the one with the,
well,
yeah.
Are just anything that goes on your head that looks like a knitted cap as it's
called in the army field manual to,
yeah,
we have that and you can check,
do gay.
I'm impartial.
I don't wear nothing.
I don't wear hats anymore as much so you don't have to have a beautiful
perfectly round head.
I guess I'm,
I'm always hiding my hair,
my hair.
When I had an easy money and I get it gets curly and then it gets like really
hard to manage.
Very,
very home manager.
I save it.
There's a picture up on my Instagram if you know,
if you followed Jodi on Instagram of me at 16 look in all kinds of rough neck
with my hair.
This I'm about this thick and my hair is just a goddamn disaster and it's
beautiful.
It's beautiful to see Jodie Medicare.
My favorite actor was Mel Gibson at the time.
I'm just going to say that I respect that big time.
It's done.
The less good stuff on there.
If you'd Jocko,
store.com that's where you get it.
If you like something,
get something.
Also Jocko white tea.
Jocko.
I,
I've yet to try Jocko white tea is really to set because I got some right here
and I've been trying it all day.
Yeah.
Oh job.
Yes.
After the show,
one of the many benefits,
if you don't know already,
which I know you already do,
you can that dead lift 8,000 pounds.
There was a guy,
he just dead lifted a bunch of weight recently.
Right.
In the rogue situation.
Yeah.
A lot of people are worried if they're competing in power lifting.
Right,
right,
right.
And Yeah.
Will you get tested for Jocko white tea and they,
they're already automatically going to know you're taking jog 20 if he did it.
Yeah.
That's kind of the task.
So you gotta be careful,
keep it at seven 7,500 in the tournament and a little bit in the cup in the
competition.
But other benefits,
our certified u s d a organic thinking about that,
you could drink a normal energy drink and become less healthy or you could drink
Jocko white tea and you can become more healthy.
That's,
is that a hard choice to make?
I don't think so.
No,
it's not even a hard choice to make drink.
What's going to make you more healthy.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't subscribed to the podcast yet.
First of all,
you have issues because there's been,
this is 169 and I used to think that everyone had subscribed at this point,
but it was actually Echo Charles the proved me wrong because somebody tweeted
like,
no,
I just subscribed for the first time,
so if you haven't subscribed,
subscribe through iTunes,
Google play,
stitcher,
whatever.
Leave some reviews.
I was reading reviews.
I always re review the reviews is what I do is that people,
it's healthy.
It's healthy to review your reviews.
All right,
and then don't forget about the warrior kid podcast as well.
Yeah,
let's not the best kids podcasts that has ever been.
Does anyone disagree with that?
I don't even know there was a kid's qualification or category or your kid
podcasting and family and two children and family or something and was like,
is the category that it's under and I'm sorry,
I did not know you had that.
The warrior could come,
came from the world,
the warrior kid podcast,
which I haven't put out as many as I should,
but there's a reason for that.
It's like
there's a lot that goes into,
I know it might not seem like it,
but there's a lot that I put into those fought.
Yeah.
It was kind of my fault.
I feel like I haven't done what all that I could have been doing to,
you know,
help make it happen.
I got to work harder.
That's what needs to happen.
So there's that.
And don't forget about the warrior kids soap,
which we have some good new samples.
You'd get the Jocko.
So if you can get the trooper,
the trooper soap has the rope,
you can hang it on soap on a rope.
Irish,
Irish oaks ranch.
Dr Opa.
Super useful.
Yeah,
it has a real purpose.
Know that.
Right?
Well,
here's the thing.
We used to make it in school.
I never knew about that.
And quiet here,
rope and like all this.
I'd be like,
oh,
that sounds cute.
You know?
And then when I say,
Oh,
soap is actually on a rope.
So you useful having the rules.
It's just kind of,
you never dropped the bar soap again.
You're good to go.
So that's Aiden.
It's a big problem.
I'm always like kid by herself.
So was making it and that way you can stay clean.
Don't forget about youtube if you want to see if you want to see echoes,
what he considers to be his legit videos.
I never considered using that word,
but then you can see him there because he thinks his videos are worth using.
I actually kind of agree with that kind of echoes.
We've got some,
he's good at the editing.
Yeah.
Either that or he just really does a lot of of editing and makes it so you'll
notice it because wouldn't it be a better editor that would make it so like
seamless that you would just not even realize it.
You just feel it.
You wouldn't notice it.
Yes.
You're saying right.
Okay.
No.
Yeah,
you're right.
When I do make those videos,
if they're good,
not the whatever.
When I do make them,
I make them for myself for sure.
Yeah.
So put it like sound effects,
like I shouldn't put sound effects while you're talking,
but I can see music because music kind of enhances or how to explosion.
Yeah.
What about crackling?
Like how she responds to the message.
You know what?
It enhances my affects that I put on.
It keeps you interested in what you're doing
in the video,
so yes you are correct.
Psychological warfare,
that's an album that you can listen to if you knew what help.
I got a moment of weakness.
It actually,
I've been,
listen,
I listened to it a lot in the last three months.
I like to hear that.
Hey,
back to your thing.
When you were,
you were saying earlier where you couldn't look at the shirt.
I couldn't wear,
I couldn't wear it.
I can look at Brighton.
That was,
I mentioned this before where I mentioned the opposite though.
It's like when you put it on you can't skip a workout now you can't sleep.
It's the same concept.
You walk straighter kind of our purpose and the look in your eye,
but like I didn't wear a Jockos.
I didn't wear any of the veteran.
Tee shirt companies like I just,
I I anyway,
yeah,
when you put it on you got to like,
you got them.
I walked out of Rehab wearing your shirt.
I like that.
And it's just these,
you know,
and this is going to sound a little corny,
but it's kind of weird.
Just weird having one of your friends pep talk you at a bed.
I've got to go ahead and say that like,
you know,
putting,
putting on your logical warfare.
I'll psychological warfare album on repeat and it's like somebody you hang with.
It's just kinda like,
I get it Jocko.
I'm a,
I need to work harder.
Okay.
You Ain't texted you yesterday.
Like I get up at six,
it's not Jocko timings,
but it's the best I can do right now.
You know what's really weird is when I have to listen to psychological warfare
myself,
that would be the most weird.
I think that is the weirdest thing or the most normal cause it's kind of like
arts,
the most amazing thing ever.
Maybe it'd be the spouse situation.
That's a good idea.
If you're a person that's trying to do something,
be good to cut yourself a couple of tracks to explain to yourself why you're
trying to do this thing.
So when the moment of weakness comes,
you could listen to me.
Sure.
But you could actually listen to yourself.
Actually that's a,
that's a great idea.
We're going to do that.
Tell him that like it's,
this is my presence or this is my future self.
It's like I've heard of people doing that and he'll be like,
okay,
I know that I'm going to be slacking on whatever and I forget what exactly what
it's for,
but there'll be like,
they'll put an audio note and they'll say,
this is your,
uh,
past self or whatever saying to you,
future echo closely.
Yes,
exactly right.
Saying,
Hey,
this is what you're thinking right now.
This is what you're feeling right now.
Don't do it.
Take it.
You know,
it's like you're talking to yourself.
I've heard of that.
Yeah.
Kelly,
I have a thing where we go,
that sounds like a problem for future Jody and Kelly,
didn't you?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly the opposite.
They're going to be like you dealt with that future Jodi Kelly,
didn't you?
Yep.
I like that.
I jog.
We're going to try that.
We'll let you know how it works.
I like it.
I'll tell you right now I,
it sounds good in theory,
but I'm all like disobey myself way quicker than I'll disobeying you.
That's a good point.
I think a lot of people like that besides the coin.
Cause eventually you'd be like,
I'm not listening to Jocko.
He's,
yeah,
he's crazy.
Right?
But then you fix yourself telling you that no escape.
If it's a goal that you set for yourself,
not my goal to go and you set for yourself.
That's true.
I'm my own worst critic,
so I don't know.
I think you know,
you're right.
Breaking your promise to yourself as well.
Way Easier.
Yeah.
Cause you might be used to that or it's weird.
I think you'd use both.
Also checkout a flipside,
canvas.com this is Dakota Meyer from podcasts for one 15
and he's selling basically bad ass prince.
Is that what you call him?
Call him prince.
Prince.
You can get prints of what really cool stuff,
you know,
movie scenes,
things.
Know,
like there's a couple of them sitting over there.
Good.
He'd get one.
He made you can get over this list.
Yeah.
Discipline equals freedom.
So yeah,
if you want us to support what's the,
it's called the flip side,
canvas.com.
And actually the reason it's called flip side is because of one of the last
things,
one of his Bros said to them before they went to that battle was I'll see you on
the flip side.
That's what the story is behind that.
So support to go to he's the man and check it out.
You can also get these,
uh,
these welder kind of reminders to you that you can just hang up and get
reminded.
Could we,
cause we need to get reminded whether it's psychological warfare,
whether it's uh,
a print,
keep yourself on the path,
whether it's a tee shirt,
keep yourself on the path.
Yeah.
These things have an impact.
The,
and those reminders are actually way more like powerful,
powerful,
but they're more powerful than you might think.
Because think about like even like with drinking or something like this where if
you have like a plan day tomorrow where it has no room for drinking that day and
no room,
no room for drinking the night before or that day if you'll have it all planned
out,
your probably you'll drink with your likelihood to drink way less.
But if you don't it's almost like you sort of forget to stay focused on what you
have to do.
You know?
Almost like a way of forgetting it was freedom.
That's why if you have a plan day like you get more done rather than because you
you fall susceptible to like what do I feel like doing?
You know your led more with what you feel or don't.
The weird thing is when you're dealing with addiction that's when you screw up
the most.
The day that you have the big presentation they'd be meeting that night before
is when you will cause that like self sabotage yourself.
That's 100% self sabotage tank cause you want to get caught cause you know
you're doing the wrong things.
You know what,
a lot of what my behavior over the last two for the last two years was like.
I hope someone,
I think psycholog or subconscious was like,
yeah,
somebody like,
cause it became my actions became almost arrogant.
Like in my boldness anyway.
We're done with all that.
Let's,
let's finish.
The commercials are so these are more like announcements to,
to stay in the past.
This is the Jocko Willink podcast.
He can do whatever he wants.
True.
It's true.
So Home Gym,
right?
We're doing home gym.
You go to [inaudible] dot com this is where you get your kettle bells.
I have all of the monkey bells that they put out five years ago.
Remember those?
I got them,
I got the mace,
the Quad Mace.
That thing as hard on it.
Yeah.
Do you have like a regular routine with the Mace?
I had one man actually Jack Time.
I actually jacked my elbows because of like all the shooting I did as a sniper.
So I had to build up my inner like cause of what's in the insight.
It's the Golfer's elbow.
Right?
This is a tennis.
Anyway,
I had to build up the tendons and then I could swim in the sea and that's what
I'm saying.
He tried to do a little routine.
If you're not used to that bro,
you'll feel all those little weirdo muscles that you have.
One of my buddies sold my house here in San Diego and he sends me a text.
He's out of town,
you know,
he's in the Daves and he goes,
he goes,
hey man,
sold the house.
Escrow closes tomorrow.
It's done.
I got a tire there and some other like bumper plates,
whatever.
If you want to go grab it,
I'm not,
I'm not taking it.
So if you want to get it,
otherwise I got to get it moved by someone.
So it was a little bit of a,
you know,
good deal for him.
Good deal for me.
It's been raining here in southern California.
Anyways,
I show up to the house and I was pretty psyched to get attire.
You know,
we're talking about a big tractor tire track or charter,
but I was thinking like a big tractor tire that you know,
you could,
you know,
easily thrown a vehicle or something like that.
It was like truth,
your mass,
some of the big foot would be huge.
It's huge.
It's absolutely huge.
I barely got it.
And you know,
my giant van,
I barely bay,
literally barely got into the most,
the biggest van you could buy.
I barely got it after it was all filled with water.
I had to get a scoop.
All the one I'm wearing my flip flops.
It was a nightmare.
So to my buddy that,
uh,
then you know who you are.
I got your tire to my backyard.
I'm psych now of course,
because now I've got a cool tire.
I also was like one of those things that kind of,
Oh,
you know,
I've got to call in like 30 minutes.
I'll just drive over there,
grab it real quick.
No,
I was out there and get barely making it back.
But you made it so don't underestimate or underestimate the tire.
That's the deal.
Clarify the tire.
Oh,
you had a tire.
You need a moving truck to move it.
Oh,
give me a heads up next.
How you figured tractor tire tractor.
You just say the tire
so that it's as tall as not as tall as me.
It's not as tall as me,
but it's be like the one here.
No,
no.
That's what I was expecting a victory at at our,
our gym here.
You know victory,
Jim.
We know we've got an,
we've got some tires.
We've got three or four of them.
Yeah.
This thing is bigger than all of them,
but a lot bigger.
But you know,
hey,
he hooked me up apparently.
Probably vague on purpose.
Yeah,
no,
he knows I'm fired up.
Right.
Most people would think Jocko longer,
I guess.
Tired.
He was an estimation jump,
jump.
Go on asking.
I know he won't ask.
I can't wait for him to go get that tight.
Little less so.
Tires or otherwise.
Home Gym boomed.
Like I said,
kettle bells rings,
jump rope.
That's a big one to forget the jump rope.
Don't forget to jump a lot of cool stuff on there.
Go to work on their feet.
If you,
I mean if you can jump around,
have you jumped rope for,
can you jump rope?
No,
I've tried it.
Just a guy though on his ankles and calves.
Uh,
I think his name's Mad Matt
on Instagram.
He's a double below knee.
I believe he's American army.
Anyway,
he jumps rope but he has like some prosthetic I haven't seen before.
So I'm going to try and get my hands on some of those.
Jumping rope is awesome.
Yup.
Unless you get them on it.com/shock we got some books.
Jody's got two books.
The first book which I covered on podcast 24 is called unflinching.
You can read,
you should,
you should definitely read it.
It's an awesome book.
Thanks man.
Yeah,
it shows the path,
the journey that Jody's been on and now you know,
the rest of the journey can hear the rest of the journey.
And he also wrote another book called Everyday Heroes,
which is,
um,
I,
cause in Canada the military books genre is not as well received,
let's say.
Um,
so,
uh,
my publisher realized there was an audience when my book hit the bestseller
list.
Um,
in Canada though,
I mean there's less people in Canada,
all of Canada than there are in California.
So it's like my kids aren't going to Ivy League schools or anything.
Uh,
but so they want,
so I wanted to do a book that would let other soldiers tell their story and I'm
hoping to make a series out of it.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's a book that I think I could do every year and never rented a material.
Uh,
so we'll pick it up everyday heroes.
It's available every Amazon and anywhere.
But some good old boys from World War II and Korea right up to Afghanistan.
One of my favorite stories is this Guy Bruno.
Uh,
he disarms a suicide bomber while the guy has his fingers on the trigger.
Yeah.
The ball like balls the size of like kettlebells.
I'm like,
so anyway,
and he's a pretty good,
cool duties.
He's out there somewhere doing the,
doing the good fight,
but
that's awesome.
Yeah.
So pick those books up.
You can all skip Mikey and the dragons best children's book
in the world.
Yeah.
Mikey,
the dragons,
biking the dragons.
You can pick that one up.
You can pick up the way.
The warrior kid way,
the warrior kid too,
which is called March mission.
Jodi,
how does your daughter like way the kid,
uh,
in her words,
it's the greatest book she's ever read and she's 10.
Yeah.
And she's a girl and she's Canadian and she's my daughter and I can't get her to
do like even Jujitsu's an argument.
I'm like,
you're doing Jujitsu when I start and she's like,
no,
I don't want to.
But for some reason that book and it sat on our shelf for a couple of months.
Yeah.
But man,
when she read it,
she said,
this is,
I didn't,
she didn't tell me she was reading it.
But you said your friend wrote the greatest book I've ever read.
She did a book report on it for school and everything was awesome.
Yeah.
I think it's one of those things you don't want to force your kid to read it.
You just put it there.
Just kind of put it out there and let them read it.
Just like any leadership position,
you don't want to force things down someone's throat.
You just make available to them the path they,
when they see it,
they get on it and there's going to be new or your kid book coming out in the
spring.
I'll let you know when it's available for preorder.
The big preorder,
the name of that.
There's some title.
That book is where there's a will.
So you've got that one coming.
You've got the discipline equals freedom field manual if you need to.
It's another little reminder for life.
It's another thing that'll keep you on the path of,
keeps me on the path.
Just have that book sitting on one of my friends that uh,
is that a hedge fund and in there,
in there,
you know,
it's like a really cool looking,
hedge funds in New York City.
All cool.
All Wolf of Wall Street type stuff.
What's the,
yeah,
sleek.
That's the modern thing.
They're very sleek and he shows me a picture of like they're there when you walk
in and you know when you walk into a hedge fund you want to,
they want to leave an impression that they know what's up.
There's this big white table,
what's on the white table,
the field men feel better.
One book just sitting there and he says,
everyone that comes in and picks it up and goes,
what is this thing?
This is awesome.
So it's perfect to be the only book to aesthetically what I'm saying,
especially if the white table or black goes with everything or a great table.
Yeah,
I get it.
It goes with everything.
It's very nice.
So get that book for yourself,
for anyone that wants to get after it more or continually extreme ownership.
We talked about that a bit today,
the lessons we learned in combat and how you can apply them to your business,
to your team,
to your family,
to your life.
Also the dichotomy of leadership,
which is now starting to creep out from its older brother's shadow cause extreme
ownership.
Everyone knows it.
Everyone loves it,
but they're like,
oh,
dichotomy out.
We don't know about your little brother.
It's kind of like you echo Jade's little brother,
right?
Yep,
sure.
Yep.
And you know,
it was Kinda like,
oh,
jade was kind of the guy,
right?
No,
came first came here is just the echo.
Right.
And jade was,
jade jade was bigger than you,
right?
Yeah,
he was.
Who's bigger now?
You see what I'm saying?
So dichotomy of leadership is like the Echo Charles of the j Charles Oh,
family
on that thread.
Like,
uh,
before my Jody medic podcast episode,
when we were coming
to meet you when he was coming,
we debated Luca and I debated if echo like eyes,
I say,
I can't wait to find out what Echo Charles,
his real name is.
And Luke says,
I hope it's Echo Charles,
because I just thought it was,
remember we talked about this Alpha Bravo.
Charlie,
right?
And then when I asked you and you're like,
no,
my name,
my name's Echo.
And why?
What's Charles mean?
And you're like,
it's,
my last name is Leslie.
I just,
just really listening to the shows by shows the other day and I was like,
I was like,
oh yeah,
can we meet to talk to echo about like how I thought for sure your real name was
like was like,
like Ernie or something.
He called you echo cause it's cooler.
It starts with an e.
We didn't want no Ernie on the podcast here.
Kind of like how you did with Tuskegee to bruise or you did that exact thing and
maybe if your name was like Ernie,
I wouldn't have to change it.
It's echo.
Echo just sounds cooler.
And then Charles was like,
because like maybe your real name was Charlie or something.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I dig it well with these books.
Good news by the way.
Books,
speaking of books,
all these you can can,
you can get everyday heroes.
All these books on Jocko,
podcast.com I got them organized.
Here's a list of books,
all of them and you can get the dichotomy of leadership there as well and
extremely all these books.
Yeah,
I got them listed on a page.
Every book we've covered podcast you ever got,
ever did here was on there.
You do now?
No,
I think I did for that original orders on your website.
I think for then originally wasn't.
Yeah.
Unflinching is for sure.
It is.
Oh thanks man.
I didn't realize that every book that we've done is on is on.
Thanks Jocko podcast episode.
That's probably why it's still selling.
It's still selling.
That's what I mean.
It's a weird thing you got to remember is that the lag time on the podcast is
there's some,
there's,
there's many,
many people that start with episode one today.
No Bro.
That's what I said.
And I say,
I get a message like weekly,
minimum one a week.
It's,
I just heard you on Jocko and,
and I go like,
I resist the urge to say,
Oh,
if you heard me on episode,
was it 24 25 to 24 25 wait till one 11 or,
and then,
you know,
because I want them to discover it on their own.
Yeah,
no,
that's one of the coolest things is people and people ask me,
where should I start on the podcast?
And I say one,
and they definitely build on each other,
but they're also timeless.
So it's not like you go,
oh well they're talking about some political thing that happened in 2014 and I
don't want to listen to that right now.
No,
it's like we're talking about something that happened 480 years ago and you do
want to hear about it.
So yeah.
But I saw the dichotomy of leadership.
Someone the other day had had wrote on Twitter.
This is the best leadership book I've ever read,
which is normally what I hear about extreme ownership.
So now I see a little little replacement there.
Jade Charles is being usurped by his younger brother.
That's what's going on.
So jade,
better stirpes to keep rooting for extreme ownership year.
You represent the dichotomy of leadership.
We got national in front of leadership consultancy.
What we do is we solve problems through leadership.
It's me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle Day,
Burke,
Flint Cochran,
Mike Cirelli,
Mike [inaudible],
and Jason Gardner.
Someone put up like Da Nang.
Everyone at this company,
he's a pipe head or no one can compete.
I was like,
hmm.
Pay.
I'm not going to say don't compete,
but we definitely have awesome guys on the team.
That's echelon front.com for details there.
We got to muster coming in 2019 May 23rd and 24th in Chicago,
September 19th and 20th in Denver.
December 4th and fifth in Sydney,
Australia.
That's right.
Go to extreme ownership.com every one of these events are sold out and all of
these are going to sell out.
They're actually selling faster than they ever sold before.
When we look at our data analytics,
the meda data,
they eat it that no one say it's,
we made it data.
How do you guys call it?
We'll work on the Canadian one after this.
Yeah,
the Canadian dates.
Yeah.
If online,
one of the reasons that we did this is because not everyone can come to the
muster.
And every time I post about the muster,
there's someone that says,
when you come to Milwaukee,
when you come into Detroit,
when he had come up to Ottawa,
and the bottom line is we can't go everywhere to do monsters.
That was one of the things that made us make this thing f on line.
The other reason is we work with companies that have tens or hundreds of
thousands of employees and they say,
oh,
can you just train all of their employees?
And I say,
well,
yeah,
sure.
And then they say,
I have 138,000 boys took,
hm,
no,
actually that's gonna be a problem.
So how to solve that problem we made eff online.
It is interactive training online that you can take you online.com we have also
eff Overwatch if you want.
If you want a combat proven special operations leader or combat aviation leader
to come and work inside your company to make things happen,
then go to [inaudible],
overwatch.com fill out the information.
Whether you're a vet that wants a position or your a talent seeker that needs
people at your company that can lead and understand the principles that we talk
about,
an extreme ownership.
Then check that out.
And if you want to keep cruising with us,
all of us can be found on the interwebs,
on Twitter and on Instagram and on the face
off or you off these book.
Now he's on Facebook.
Echo is adequate.
Charles.
I am at Jocko Willink and Jodi is at Jody Mitic Echo.
Anything else?
I have nothing else.
Thank you.
Thank you for having nothing else.
Jody,
anything else
brother?
Thank you Jackie.
Thank you,
Echo.
Thank you to the listeners and um,
you know,
I,
I'm working on being the best Jody I can be then thanks for being there with,
for me and uh,
with Kelly and I,
it's good that you have like a new mission.
Remember that was one of the best ways I've ever heard it.
Heard it put like you need a mission.
So man,
if you don't have like an important mission,
like really cared.
I mean,
sure I got,
I know what I got to do tomorrow in the next month and all that stuff.
But if it's not like that important to you,
right,
you're going to be like all I need.
That's what happened Bro.
The politics getting in DePaul it winning,
what's a great mission.
And then I won and then I was like the dog that caught the car.
Yay.
I was like,
okay,
what do I do now?
And I tried to learn and I,
I,
you know,
I had the deputy mayor and the mayor and they were all on my side and I had lots
of like they all,
we still talk,
but my,
my,
they could say that cause he could see it.
My heart just wasn't in it.
You know,
like Kelly would always say,
she would always say,
man,
you know,
when you get excited,
when you talk about like going here to see the troops are going there and
shooting and going there and like planning and up that business.
You've,
oh I wanted to open a gym since before I got blown up,
you know,
and now I'm back on it.
And I thought I could do both.
I thought being the counselor would let me like,
you know,
have a spot open it,
like be there for meetings is,
but it's just like,
it's just not,
doesn't work.
Not For me anyway.
Maybe if I go,
like I might get political again in my fifties after I make a few bucks and it's
a little less more to pay the bills.
And so it's a little less about paying the bills and more about getting things
done.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
And so we didn't know,
but right now I need to be myself for a while.
And so that's it for like 10 year plan is to be Jody.
Boom,
chuck him,
as Echo said,
that's a new mission.
The new mission with the place that you're developing and you know,
to unplugging for as long as they did.
I didn't realize how much you're doing and burrow,
like the respect I have for you actually just went up hearing up and it's not
like I,
it's not like it can go much higher,
don't get too egotistical.
But you know,
a guy like me thinking you're awesome but mia,
my point is everything you're doing is for the community.
And I had a sit down actually shot show 2017.
One of the guys I taught on his basic sniper sat,
he's an,
he's one of the best snipers in Canada.
Uh,
one of our soft commanders.
He said,
uh,
you need to stop.
[inaudible] was another guy who told me you can do more for the community as
Jody medic and working for yourself than for working for Colt or de Macko were
any of these other companies that I was looking at and you know,
and,
and it's being able to take,
take the reigns of leadership that you have and start doing the things listening
to you talk.
I'm like,
because Kelly and I,
like,
we have a five and 10 year plan where we hope we can have an employment website
where we hope we can have a speaking bureau that can take guys,
have a similar mindset and have us have a presence and put them out there
delivering a good message.
And,
and you're doing all that and you're being a,
an example for my kids,
dude.
And like,
cause then,
you know,
takes a village to raise a kid.
And I,
and I want my daughters to know all the best people in the world.
And you know,
you're one of them in and you're just everything you're doing with the people
around you.
Like,
um,
I have,
I have someone that's leading the way for me,
uh,
and I,
and I'm glad it's not just me doing it either,
is that,
makes it like I'm waving,
I'm 10 years behind you,
but,
but now I know it's a,
it's possible too.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
um,
there's,
there's plenty of room,
there's all kinds of people in the world that are down to move forward and move
on.
And,
yeah,
and there's plenty of pie for everybody.
That's the word right now in Canada.
We're dealing with a little bit of like a too much competition,
not enough collaboration.
And as far as the tactical after army world,
um,
but you know,
and the reason I kept throwing an Ottawa,
Canada,
there's cause they're hungry for Jocko in Canada and,
and you and we should talk because we have a little barrier.
We have a little bit,
but I'm telling you,
it's probably bigger than you realize.
Okay.
So anyway,
I just wanted to throw that in.
You said anything else and I just listening to you talk,
it gives me hope that everything I want to do is achievable.
There's no doubt about it.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm an average dude that I'm a hard worker.
I will say that,
but nothing special in any other way.
And I just,
just,
and you're a good person and good people attract good people and you,
you know,
if you were hard to work with,
people wouldn't work with you.
And that's one thing I've learned.
Like,
you know,
if you want good people around,
you have to be good
person.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's awesome to work with all the guys that I work with before and we're all
working together again.
As actually with Jason Garner,
we were just laughing because he got back from his gig.
I got back from my gig and he was just laughing and saying,
this is so awesome,
man.
This is so awesome.
Year round.
All the people you were around in uniform,
you can help each other again.
That's what it's all about,
man.
Roger,
when it's all about,
and speaking of those people in uniform that allow us to do this podcast,
people like you,
Jody,
all of our military personnel and and also the police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMT and correctional officers and border patrol
and all the first responders that are out there in uniform.
All of you allow us the freedom and security that we have and that we relish
every single day that allow us these opportunities.
So thanks to every single one of you for providing it and to everyone else that
is listening.
We talk about the path,
okay?
And we talk about discipline and we talk about living clean.
But it is not an easy path.
It is filled with temptations and pitfalls and hazards and traps,
okay?
And it's hard to stay on the path.
And if you fall off,
it can seem even harder to get back on.
But you can do it,
okay?
You gotta be honest with yourself.
Do not be a slave.
Don't be a slave to drugs or booze or emotion or whatever weakness is trying to
be your master.
Don't allow it.
Tell the truth.
Call out your own weaknesses.
Then impose discipline.
Impose your will and climb back up onto the path and set your cell
free.
And until next time,
this is Jody Mitic,
an echo and Jocko
out.